Hello!
Blah!
You want to give a blah?
Uh...
Blah!
Hi everybody, welcome to a very beautiful Friday.
Happy Friday.
TGIF!
TGIF.
We're playing a game from 2013.
It's It's older than Metal Gear Solid 5.
Yeah.
That's why we played it, because this is a Metal Gear Solid 5 reference.
Is it?
Yeah, because this is during when Snake was sleeping.
Oh, yeah.
It's been nine years.
This is what, like, Kai's was developing.
He was gaming.
He was fucking gaming.
Do you think Love Bloom's on the BattleBlock Theater?
Oh, yeah.
Actually, I know nothing about this game, Barry.
Oh, wait.
You should give an introduction.
Oh, okay.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Barry, and I'm a bug.
I'm a ladybug to be ex...
Oh.
Continue.
I have a...
Ladybug to be exact.
What the fuck?
Why would you say that?
It's fine.
It's just, you know.
I'm actually afraid of ladybugs a little bit.
Have I ever told you that?
No, you haven't.
You even let me into your bed.
Yeah, Barry and I have shared a bed before.
To you.
That's not all we've done.
What else have we done?
We've shared a Denny's pancake.
It was good, though, that Denny's pancake.
I definitely didn't give Barry...
I definitely couldn't finish...
Or, no, I definitely did not...
Wait, how the...
Hold on.
It's definitely not that I couldn't finish it and give Barry my leftovers.
Yeah, I just happened to come at the end and everyone was like...
Everyone was like, yeah, just eat leftovers.
I was just...
Everyone gave me their leftovers.
Like, Barry, are you hungry?
You have pancakes.
Barry, are you hungry?
You have...
What else was there?
I love mooching.
I think I ate, like, someone's bacon.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think Maddie offered me her bacon or something.
And then...
We hung out a couple times.
We even went to Knott's Berry Farm.
Yeah!
And we went on that one roller coaster where you lie down when you're looking at each.
Wait, we were also next to each other on the pony ride.
Yeah, we were doing umapyoi.
We were like umapyoi, umapyoi.
We were front row, baby.
And yeah.
The seats like strapped us in.
It was crazy.
It made us have like a very sexy pose.
because it like accentuated your your butt so basically the ride you're riding a pony like that's how the seat is and then there's also like a back part that like pushes you your it pushes you against the seat too and so your butt's sticking out and you're like i'm i'm riding this pony this is sexually i want to be a cowboy baby baby what did they say save a horse ride a cow boy do they say that i think so whoa that's crazy yo who is they it's they they the people yeah them the guys yeah everybody says that wait it's a song lyric oh oh i didn't know that i didn't know for thank you for all the support everybody and all the donations uh we'll probably i think minto might do it after uh or like after the collab too but i'll do everything after the collab yeah um yeah focus all my all my uh attention on the minto
why did you why did you react like that
I know you've seen the fan art I know you've seen the fan art of me being a freak Oh yeah like you Taking pictures of me in bed I didn't do that though Those are all allegations I would never do that I would never listen to Minto sleeping And be like wow
It's true!
I'm so innocent.
Don't I look innocent?
Your face?
What about my face?
Basically, we're like, Don't I look innocent?
I'm innocent, man.
We're so innocent together.
Yeah.
This is the most innocent collab.
Wait, what's L buttons?
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Yeah, we can change our colors.
Oh my goodness.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey.
What are we gonna do?
I'm gonna close my eyes and then I'll pick a color.
Okay, okay, okay.
This one!
Mid-fan pole.
It's you!
Why you like me!
Yeah!
You like me!
I was thinking we could do green because I have green in my thing and you're minto.
Okay, we could do green.
Yeah.
Alright, ready up.
How do I read it?
I'm ready.
Just kidding.
I've never played this game before, you guys.
This is a new experience for me.
Yeah, you don't know anything about this game, right?
Literally nothing.
I'm just a triangle man.
Oh!
Shit!
Look at you, triangle.
Wait, I want the scarf.
Oh.
Oh, cute.
You like this one?
Yeah, I like that one.
There's like a bunch of faces.
I only played this for, like, a tiny bit.
So I have some faces unlocked.
Wait, you have so many.
What are you talking about?
Apparently, apparently you can also...
Okay, I didn't know this because I guess I did this like four years ago or something.
But I guess somebody gave me like a PNG to work with.
Do you see this?
No, it just has like...
It's you in a hood and then your face...
You look like...
You look like Squid Game.
So I guess if you upload your own PNG...
it like kind of doesn't Oh, I like the tongue That one is freaky Not that one I like the tongue You like that one Yeah The freaky one
That one's good too Here I'll do the tongue I'll do the tongue Okay Yeah You're gonna lick me You're gonna lick me Yeah, I'm gonna Oh, how do you Oh, oh Oh,
fuck you!
Wait, you have the star!
Oh, wait, we both have the star.
Yeah, oh, wait, I just...
How did I unlock the castle crashers?
That's castle crashers, right?
Wait, I've unlocked some...
Yeah, I think it's just...
We'll see.
Oh, I went in...
Okay, I'm coming.
Are we prisoners?
Yeah, we're...
I...
Yeah, I think we are.
Wait, did it play the intro?
I don't...
Not crazy?
No, it didn't.
Uh-oh.
A trade by Hiding.
Maybe it'll play here.
It did not play the intro.
Does it usually play the intro?
You might have to host it.
Because I think I played this like 10 years ago somehow.
Oh, yeah.
Because it even is showing like all of these is complete, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I think you might have to host my bad.
That's okay.
I'll just...
Wait, if I...
Reset level, maybe?
Yeah.
Reset level?
I think it's fine.
I don't know if we...
No, maybe?
Oh, wait.
How is this?
Did I do it?
No?
I didn't do it.
I think you might have to host.
Okay.
So there's like a story or...
Yeah, there's a story.
There's like a cute intro.
Oh.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Exit game.
Okay.
I...
Oh, I forgot to ask everybody.
How's the audio?
Oh, yeah.
Let us know if the audio is okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Online.
And then I host.
I think the main voice actor from this game is a...
Stampy, I think.
I don't know if you know that name, but he was like a...
He's like a Newgrounds guy.
I don't really know any Newgrounds stuff, but...
Apparently, it was like a pretty big deal.
Stampy?
Stamper?
Someone like that?
Oh, Stamper?
Stamper?
My bad.
Wait, oh.
I don't want to... Oh, oh.
Oh, I have nothing.
Okay.
That's why I have nothing.
Now let me... How do I invite you?
I still don't know how you stand.
Here, I can join your game.
There we go, there we go.
Oh, you joined?
Oh, I just, oh, I sent you an invite.
Okay, just kidding.
Okay, we're here anyway.
You're here, right here.
Yeah.
You doing that face.
Coggle ready.
Well, it's gone by me.
Here we go.
Woo!
Woo-hoo.
Good evening, boys and girls, ladies, hmm, and gentlemen.
Turn the lights down, though.
Shut your faces as I wrap you in the cozy blanket of a story a story is heartwarming and soft as a mother's kiss or is it?
Once upon a time there was a boat now.
This wasn't just any boat children.
It was a ship a ship full of friends hundreds of hundreds of them Wow, I've never had them in it was get it?
It wouldn't be very ladylike of me if I didn't mention the most noteworthy friend on board Hattie Hattie Hattie Hattie was like King friend friend to one and all oh where's his heart handsome gentlemen now one fine morning patty and pals set out for a new exciting adventure what fantastic wonders would they discover this time perhaps they'd come across yeah everyone say hi to haddy they'd find an island made entirely of candy perhaps they'd meet a band of scary swashbuckling pirates and join forces to find an island made entirely of candy oh so long as they were together there was smiles to be had an adventure Adventure Day spirits were on crushably high.
Everyone was singing and dancing and having a jolly time When the sun made the ocean was all like surprise and a huge massive storm blew it out of nowhere Was you was you was you something?
No, I was quick.
Oh my god And the wind boom Didn't like that.
It was over.
Is everyone okay?
Said Hattie.
I don't know what I'd do if I lost even one of you.
I think we lost last one but the eye of the storm is very misleading children never turn your back on it because the ocean was all like psych and it came back even bigger this time twice as big would you show you as if Poseidon himself extended his hand in friendship and they they're having fun though look at them they're all yeah they're having fun they're all oh my god and the rain came down like a shower of bullets ah and the floorboards were and pieces of their ship were raining down like shards of broken dreams and then Reginald comes upstairs and he's like I say gentlemen I do believe we're in quite a spot of father and everyone else was like really what tips you off genius hey be nice huge giant waves thrash the boats to and fro they're not smiling anymore oh no we lost friends the friends everyone was screaming like was this huge whale like and made it super scary.
Oh my god, man on fire.
Man on fire.
Yep, there he is.
Oh god.
Who is that?
And then Hattie was our like, hold on to your butts.
Land ho and bang, bang, bang, smash.
A shipwreck.
Yes, foretold by their fate books of fate.
And while it seems like the end, this is merely the beginning of another fantastic journey for the brave crew of the SS Friendship.
Hell yeah.
There we go, this is the intro.
Ah!
Yeah.
Hello, look at my tongue.
Blah.
Keep up.
Oh, look at the cat.
The cat?
Yeah, you're the cat.
Oh, what the?
The door.
Fuck you.
Ah, fuck you.
Dude.
What the heck?
Hey.
Hey!
Ah!
How did you do that?
Oh my god!
Ow!
What the f- Oh, oh, shot.
Oh!
Ow!
Let's- Don't do it again.
Oh, ow!
What the- Ah!
Yeah, that's right.
Wait!
Uh-oh.
Ow!
Ah!
I'm sure how to...
Okay, so...
Maybe you could change it in the...
Oh, hey!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah?
Oh, wait.
So we have different weapons.
That's fine.
You can change your weapon in the player select.
In the setup.
Where you change your face.
Oh, no, there's only one for me.
That's okay.
Oh.
Aw, Mei!
Ha!
Oh, we're going to get tickets.
I guess I played this game before.
Oh, my God.
I think I played a good amount of this game before, maybe.
I think so, too.
Like, like, 10 years ago, maybe.
What the hell?
I don't remember anything about this, though.
You think that guy is...
Fine?
Yeah.
Oh, I didn't even...
I was looking at the cat in the background.
I think he's fine.
Okay.
By the way, all the friends that died on this...
ship it's you guys the viewers who are watching this no oh look there's someone back here you will never see this oh we'll never see a movie maybe is that a guy in the bushes or hmm oh it is send help oh now it's giving us a tutorial yeah do you think do you think that people would or hey hey you think that people would uh be nefarious no oh
so oh i see oh oh there's still people living here way buried this is like a ghost story yeah it is oh oh and look he's made some wonderful new friends oh and they got him a present how thoughtful hey wait a second i don't think that was a present but he's crying no he's sad now he's no longer happy you yet oh no they see you quench your butt this isn't gonna be good the narration is crazy what is happening oh no now we're here okay let's
go so we are listeners yeah oh wow oh there we go yeah interesting now we have the whole we've been betrayed but it's not his fault he's possessed yeah i don't think hattie would do that to us oh they're still showing check marks but maybe that's i think that might be because of me my bad that's okay i will curse my younger self for playing this damn game all right i'm i'm i'm you lead you lead I'm leading.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean, you should swim.
He just said don't fall and...
Okay.
Oh.
Good job.
Ow!
You deserve that.
No!
Oh!
Oh, come on.
Oh, what do you mean?
RT.
Oh!
Oh, come back, come back.
Oh, just kidding.
Okay.
And then I go.
I'll lift you up.
Lift me?
Lift me.
It's so lift me.
You lived me?
Lived me?
Oh!
Oh shit!
Um...
How'd you get up there?
Oh, you go on the lava block.
Oh!
Wait, oh!
Oh, it's here.
Oh, dang it.
There we go.
Oh, wow!
Crazy.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah, I would work for, I always work towards, uh, with my friends.
We work towards friendship.
Yeah, we work towards friendship.
Oh, watch out for the water.
Is that, so there's like secret things too that you get?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like the yarn and stuff?
Oh, we're missing one.
Oh, there it is.
I got it.
Yeah.
That's it!
Woo!
We did it!
Easy.
Yeah, why was he hatty before getting the hat?
he was gonna be happy.
Maybe it was always meant to be.
Ah.
We're too good at this.
Well, we are.
This music.
Wait, how do we get up there?
Wait, let me throw you?
Throw me.
Okay.
Oh, no, wait.
No, wait.
Hold on.
Okay, throw me the other way.
Turn around?
No, no.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, there you go.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You can throw me.
I'll take it.
Wait, what is this?
That worked.
That was, that was the, I meant to do that.
Oh, okay.
Perfect.
Oh, why'd you do that?
Why'd you do that to me?
It was a mistake.
Oh, wait.
You gotta go down.
You got this?
Thank you.
Easy.
It was so easy.
I didn't know why you couldn't do it.
I would.
Wait.
Oh, there's something over there.
You're right.
Oh, I need you.
Yeah, you do.
What does that mean?
Oh, oh.
Wait, hold on.
I have to wait.
Here, I'll be set up.
Okay.
I'm set up.
That was so easy.
No, I didn't die at all.
I don't think so.
As long as one of us is alive.
Yeah, I think...
Wait, but we...
We've just died together, so I guess it's fine.
Yeah, I think it's mostly a time thing, maybe.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Thank you.
Yeah, I just wanted us to get the gem.
Yeah, of course.
Wait, how do I...
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Is there something...
Oh.
What the heck was that?
No, you can go.
Oh, it's...
No, nothing.
No, no.
Nothing.
No, nothing.
I love...
Let me go to the right, maybe.
Maybe down.
Mm.
Okay, let's bring it up.
Yeah, you try.
Oh, oh, shit!
Ah!
Wait, he's freaky.
He sees your tongue.
He thinks I'm one of them.
Are you?
You do know there's an eight plus, right?
No.
There's no tongue toggle on them.
There is none.
No one will ever...
Yeah.
Oh, you see, you actually made it easier.
Oh!
Hey, wait a minute.
You got the gem!
Good job!
What the heck?
I can't...
Stay.
Stop dead.
She's dead.
She's beating my ass!
Oh!
What's this?
Oh my god.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
I smacked him down.
I smacked him.
Okay, okay.
Ah, ah, ah!
Yeah, kill that guy.
Yeah, punch him.
Kill him, kill him.
Kill that guy.
Oh.
Yeah, kill that guy.
Oh, you can actually drown him.
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Wait, how am I supposed to get this?
I don't think you can go through cloud blocks.
You gotta go.
Oh.
Ooh.
Oh!
Do it?
Did I take both of them?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, no.
wait no wait hold on okay oh wait i got it how do you hold on oh okay hold on okay hold on okay hold on no no okay hold on hold on wait hold on okay hold on okay okay okay okay okay why why was that so bad what do you mean that wasn't so bad no no we're good no yeah let's Whoa!
Whoa!
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Oh, I think I need to throw you.
Or wait, what's down here?
Oh.
Go get it.
I didn't try to do anything.
Come here.
Thank you.
I didn't mean to do that.
I'm sorry.
I have trust issues, but Maybe I can trust Minko.
You can trust.
Maybe I can trust...
Oh, he's so cute!
Oh, he's like, hey, he's just...
We just murdered him.
No, that was your fault, though.
No, what is this?
A boat!
Oh, I think you got a key...
Uh, uh, yeah, I go.
You can go.
And then I'll catch you.
Okay.
You promise to catch me?
me yes okay i'm i'm trusting you oh thank you you should be on this boat
shoot this game is so fun yay yeah oh we did it we did go to the gift shop too yeah it's been your gems what gems are we having here that the ones oh my god it's haddy Oh, wait, gotcha!
Patty!
Oh, yeah.
Unlock some prisoners.
Oh, wait.
We need 10 gems, though.
Oh, we have 10.
No, I'm different.
I don't think my luck was very good.
I didn't have to use that one.
I do?
You got it, so you have to, right?
It's like your first SSR in the game.
Right.
Wait, what's a concession device?
It's like basically, I think it's just the heads, like the different heads, but, um...
Oh.
Like if you look, this is like the triangle head.
Oh, that's a triangle one.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I guess I'll change.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
You got goods.
You have five?
I don't think we have five yet.
I have five.
I have seven.
Oh!
Wait, I can get a new weapon.
to him can you can you not press like uh what's here i don't know how you did the concession no it doesn't land me rt no i like over here oh wait training post maybe here oh oh no i don't want what do you mean you don't want it barry why not barry why don't you want my head huh why don't you want my face huh why don't you want it why don't you want it why don't you want it Oh shit.
What do you need to give me?
Okay, I can give you...
Do you want this one?
No.
No, I'll keep mine.
I'll keep it.
It's fine.
Okay.
I'll keep mine.
I just need to...
I don't know how to...
Wait, do I switch in their player setup?
Oh, there we go.
Okay, are you ready for this?
You're gonna have to stare at it the rest of the game.
What?
What am I looking at?
I'm off the screen.
Hold on, I'm looking at something to give you.
You said you wanted the scarf, right?
You want a scarf?
No, but this is the one I got.
It's okay.
All right, you're right.
How do I get out?
Oh, there we go.
We're at soaps.
We're, um, we're, um...
Guys, we're here to save our friends!
Yeah!
Our friends!
Wait, how do I...
Can you say hide?
Like, can you say, uh...
Oh, I didn't mean to run back into him.
Can you pay him?
I feel like you should be able to pay him.
It doesn't, there's no prompt that comes up at all.
Ow!
Why'd you do that?
In front of me.
What the hell?
I thought I could maybe take you down with me.
Oh.
Wait, there's some stuff over here, though.
What's this?
Oh, more gotcha?
Yeah, I think these are the other faces.
Bottom floor prisoners, props upstairs.
It didn't let me.
Maybe you don't have enough?
It's yarn balls.
Oh, it's not gemmings.
Yeah, mine, apparently mine doesn't count if I redo the level, so I didn't know how much you were mad.
Oh, okay, okay.
All right.
We need to get more gems.
Let's go!
Why does something's not right with my minto?
What do you mean?
What's wrong with me?
What's wrong with me, Berrybug?
You don't think I look okay?
She's becoming violent.
The music is really just sets the tone here, I think.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
My nipple.
No, please.
Ah.
Ow.
Oh.
Get out of here.
Wait, hold on.
Oh.
I won't miss.
I won't miss, hold on.
Are you doing it?
Yep, yep.
I'm doing it, I'm doing it.
Oh, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I guess that worked.
I did it.
Uh-oh.
What, how?
I just did it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I just did it, too.
Yeah, good job.
Oh!
Mystery!
It's a secret!
Oh, Bailey Bug, you're on my head!
Yeah!
Billy Bug!
Oh, sorry.
Your head is very pointy as well.
Oh, oh!
Let me up!
Here, I got you.
Okay, Bailey Bug.
Thanks so much.
Wait, Boo!
We gotta get the gem!
Gotta get the gem.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
I'm going.
Okay.
I said, oh, right.
Whoa.
Oh, gosh.
Family bug!
Oh, family bug!
Why did you say family bug?
That wasn't my fault.
Wait.
How do I do this?
Oh, here I go.
You left me hanging.
Oh, no, no.
I...
Oh, oh, oh.
I didn't do anything.
Oh, Bailey bug.
Help me, Bailey.
I don't from you.
Oh, she dessert.
Wait.
Oh, we BAW.
All right, wait.
I don't think it's okay.
I'm sorry.
The timing.
Wait.
Wait, why'd you end up over there?
Because I made it through.
I don't know, actually.
Ah!
This is so messed up.
Yeah, get him, get him, push him.
Oh!
I double teamed up.
Yeah.
You killed them.
The skin of a killer, belly bug.
Belly bug.
Oh!
Can we get everything?
Maybe I think so.
Yeah, the art style is very like Adobe Flash.
Yeah, it's fine.
I did, too.
Oh, wait, we missed one.
Wait, we missed two.
How?
Wait, we're the worst at this game.
Uh-oh.
We're the worst.
We're the absolute worst.
Woo!
Oh, that's fine.
You just made the sound that they usually make the woo.
Oh.
Were you a voice?
Sack for us for this game?
Oh, oh, wow.
It's already open.
That's crazy.
Is the game a little quiet for you guys?
I can turn it up.
It feels so loud, though, in my ears.
Yeah, yeah, same ear.
Ah!
Oh, I didn't look.
I'm waiting for it.
Hi.
Hi, game.
Have you ever played the Flash games, though?
I'm sure you have, but have you ever played them, like, recently?
Not recent.
Oh.
Yeah, I used to play Flash games on Newgrounds.
Yeah, oh!
What was your favorite?
Did you play Meat and Fuck Kingdom?
Oh, yes!
Wait, okay, so you're the dude?
No, I didn't!
Oh, wait, you didn't?
You did?
Yeah.
Really?
Yeah, I used to play all the Meat and Fuck games.
And then I played like the Galaxy Angel game and the Love Hina game and the Naruto game.
Wait, really?
That's crazy.
And then Zone used to also upload on there.
And so there was like a Midna like a screwing simulator.
Wow.
I think you're much more... I was never really a Newgrounds person.
I was like a mini clip.
I played like Happy Wheels and stuff.
Ah!
Happy Wheels.
What's that?
Yeah, it's a, it's a, like, a flash game that, where you, like, drive.
And it's, like, very gory and silly.
I got it.
I made it.
Oh, wait.
Come here.
Help.
Me too.
Thank you.
Ah!
Why did you do that, Barry?
I didn't mean to do that.
You're...
Oh.
Two.
Ah!
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah.
Oh, Me too.
Why did you do that?
Let me help you out.
I live.
Oh, sorry.
I like the way I stare and like...
Yeah, what?
So, with your three eyes.
There we go.
Oh, what's happening?
Nope, nope, I'm not letting you off.
Oh.
What's this do?
Oh!
That's fine.
Oh, it's...
It's ectoplasm.
Except it's...
Oh.
Wrong color.
Oh!
I want this.
Wait.
What's that there?
There's a spy?
Oh my gosh!
I'm sure it does kill...
Maybe we have to...
Ouch!
He licked me.
What a freak!
Stop it!
I think I don't know...
Oh, you killed yourself.
Is that what I did?
Yeah, I did.
I think you landed on your own mind.
How do we get this?
Ready?
Oh, what the?
I didn't even know that.
Oh, wait.
How do you...
How do we get to there?
Wait, it doesn't go...
Oh, no.
It doesn't go through.
No.
I think you have to...
I think...
Here, let me just throw you over there.
Okay.
Oh, wrong way.
Oh, wrong way, sorry.
Turn around.
Get it.
Oh.
Oh, easy.
that seems like all of them right yeah I think so no wait hold on yeah that's that's lilac made exercise oh yeah that's lilacs wow wait we match look at us oh true true hell yeah hell yeah Okie dokie.
Okie dokie.
I'm calling the boat.
Just kidding.
Oh, the boat's over there.
You gotta...
Oh, like that.
I started it.
Oh.
Oh, you dropped it.
Okay, nice.
Now call it over.
I'm calling it over.
No!
Med Phantom!
What's wrong, family bug?
Me!
Come over here!
Wow, you're like...
You're like patting the water so seductively?
It's like...
Really, it's drawing me in like a siren.
This is my mating ritual.
Oh.
Oh, um...
Oh, Minto.
I'm fine.
Oops.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I just saw you try to assassinate me.
I did, I did, I did actually.
I did.
I did just try to kill you, I did.
I'm gonna try to kill you too.
Oh, there!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Stop the violence!
Okay, now, oh, you got it.
Help me!
Come here, me!
Wait, what's this do?
Here, let me throw you over.
What a thrill!
Oh yeah, throw me over?
Yeah.
There you go.
Climb up!
I'm coming, I'm coming!
Don't!
What a thrill!
With the darkness!
Oh, climb that, yeah, climb that.
Okay, I'm climbing.
Nice, nice.
Yeah, I killed him.
Oh, wait, I missed!
Wait, how do you find this?
Oh, you have to write RT.
You have to hold it.
Yeah, you have to hold it.
Wait.
Oh, sorry, that was me.
Yeah, that was you.
There you go.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Dude, this is so freaking epic!
What is this?
a secret oh oh where am i uh where am i oh you're up there oh i'm up here oh wait wait wait this is so much easier you don't have to do a bunch of stuff to get up here oh what a what a thrill what a freaking thrill whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait there's a secret there's a secret don't go i didn't mean to don't wait i didn't mean to i didn't mean to get the secret no wait wait i We missed.
Yeah, I only want to.
We got everything else.
I wish you could, like, go back through the one level.
You can.
Oh, you can?
Yeah.
Do we want to?
Um...
If you want to, but I think there's, like, a lot of levels.
Okay.
We'll just keep going.
Yeah.
It's okay.
We never look back.
Wee!
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I'm here.
She got distracted.
It was made for climbing.
Why does a ladder exist if not to climb?
Exactly.
Ooh, what the hell is that?
What the fuck?
Ooh, the music is really good.
I'm going to take a meow.
Oh, I made it.
Oh, how do I get out?
Oh, you got to climb?
Yeah, you got to climb.
Okay.
Oh, boom.
That was me.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
I thought you an enemy.
My bad.
That's fine.
No one will hear you scream.
No, what do you mean?
Oh, wait!
No one will hear you scream.
Wait, these games get crazy.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait!
Oh, sorry!
Okay, I'm going.
Oh, you're going.
Oh, okay.
Oh, no, you're...
You go?
Okay.
Oh, oh, we both...
Ah!
One of us lived.
Oh, quickly, wait!
Push me!
What's up?
Ah!
Oh, berry bug.
Oh, you made it.
Yeah, I made it.
Oh, whoa!
Sorry.
I thought I could make it.
How did you- What happened?
What happened?
Hey!
Okay, get me.
Grab me.
Okay, I got you.
Okay, you got me.
Guys, she's got me.
Oh, okay, I got you.
She's got me.
I got you.
Nice.
Yeah, see, I got you.
We got, yeah.
We're good friends.
Yeah, we're good friends.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Here, I'll throw you instead.
Oh, that's, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, that was close.
That was close?
Yeah.
See?
Look at me.
Yeah, we're fine.
Helpful.
Everything's good.
I just wanted to help you.
I just...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Why are you laughing?
Why?
Come on, Berry Button.
Who are you?
I can't.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, I didn't do that, though.
I can't.
Okay, I didn't do that though.
Okay, thank you.
Alright, here I go!
Oh!
Oh, and then you have to drop the boat for me.
Yeah.
Thank you, Minko.
Hey, look at us.
We're...
Go get it.
Me?
Yeah.
Trust.
Okay, okay.
I knew you'd make it.
Wait, who was that?
That guy has a deformed head.
Oh, he's carrying one!
He's stealing it!
Yea, get him!
Oh, get him!
Yeah, yeah, get him!
I had him.
Get him!
Oh, he's...
Oh, he's dying.
Wait.
I got it.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
He sacrificed himself.
Oh, me too.
Wait, there's a secret.
I can feel it.
Yeah.
Oh.
Good job.
Wait, what is this?
This is like suspicious.
Maybe it's not suspicious.
Maybe.
I think we're good.
Yay!
I think that's all of it, right?
I don't think we missed anything.
I guess we'll see.
We're definitely not making time.
We missed one!
Wait, we didn't win!
What happened?
I thought we got everything.
I know.
What the heck?
Oh.
Oh!
Is there a bow?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, he's looking.
Oh, he's down.
Zed pull it yeah nice um wait how do we okay okay okay come here
oh oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah anyway i'm gonna ignore that happen
we're not making time oh oh you're right you're right my bad jeez oh we're speed i gotta speed run this
What is it?
What's the mystery here?
Oh, there's a secret.
Yeah.
I think you gotta like slide through it.
Oh, okay.
Like that.
Oh, there you go.
Go.
I'm here, I'm here.
Okay, okay.
Oh, and then I go up here.
Okay.
And then I go.
And then you go.
Don't do that!
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay, we're back, we're back.
We're back, okay.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's good, everything's fine.
Oh, wrong, wrong, wrong.
Yeah, yeah, wrong.
Whoopsie.
Let me in.
Oh my gosh, look at that.
the way i'm like you're just so happy i look like a dog like galloping like
oh be careful oh good job oh be careful oh oh oh oh they just got to run with confidence you know oh good job good job good job i'm like i'm sniffing them out how do i get out oh Be careful!
Be careful!
Ah!
Oh, what does this do?
Got it?
Oh, nice, nice.
Now do you think we got all of them?
I don't know.
Oh, there's something here.
There's something here.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'll check it out.
Oh, just kidding.
No, keep going up here?
Keep going here.
And then it does this.
Now you can go.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, I had to stop the laser.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, we did it.
Yeah!
There's not like a die encounter, is there?
I don't...
Maybe there is later in the game, but I don't think there is yet.
I'm sure there is like a stat tracker though.
Are you a real rabies survivor?
Um, what?
You think I would just steal...
Oops, sorry.
You think I would just steal Valor like that?
I don't think I can make that.
I think you gotta go on ahead.
Okay.
Oh, I got you.
Yeah.
I guess.
Here, I'll climb on your head.
Oh, ouch.
I died from that.
That's crazy.
My bad, my bad, my bad, my bad.
I think you gotta jump.
There you go.
Yeah, I got it.
Get out of here.
Kill him, kill him.
Oh, he's on me.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
You've been speared.
Oops, I did it again.
Uh-oh.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh, I'm fine.
We're fine.
Oh, Daya, hello.
Thank you for the raid.
Thanks for the favor.
Welcome in.
I knew it.
Oh, wait.
She's thinking?
I knew it.
It's because I played meat and fuck.
I know.
This is my era.
Don't say that.
You're...
You just know.
I hope you had fun playing horse Plinko.
Thank you again for the raid.
I'm Barry and this is Minto and welcome to Jack.
yes yeah we are acting kind of dumb oopsie okay oh we're good team we're good team oh whoops i didn't even do that was it fun i'm just so i'm i didn't even know you could i mean i guess i knew you could play but i never thought about oh was meeting and fun the games got like super crazy they did Oh.
Oh.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Wait, actually.
Yeah, what's over there?
Yeah, I might need you.
Come get me.
All right.
Sorry.
Oh, I'm up here.
Oh, wait.
Come on, hurry up.
Oh, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
It's fine.
You got it.
Wait, I think that was it.
Wait, is there anything up here?
No, it's just the eyes.
Okay.
Hmm.
I'm coming.
The game's got, like, kind of crazy with, like, with, like, quests and everything.
They were fine.
I liked them.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
We're not going to want to go anymore.
You're just not going to want to.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah.
Oh, wait, wait.
I missed the...
Oh, me too.
Oh, I'm drowning.
Wait, do we go...
Is this, like, an instance where you go left and I go right?
That's what I was thinking.
So...
Oh.
Well...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, no!
It's good to go the other way.
Okay, I'll go once I can.
Yeah, I believe in you.
I believe in you.
Oh my gosh, the screen is so small now.
It's just better to look at everything, Liz.
Better to look at me, my dear.
Yeah, let's do it.
We did it.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, thank you.
Woo!
Oh, oh, oh.
Hey we made it easy peasy.
We're watching here.
Oh yeah.
Oh, you got them.
You got them, you got them.
Oh, I'm sorry, I love you.
You got them.
I got him.
I got another thing.
Yeah, I think so actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
One, two, three.
I think there's seven per now.
I think it's, it seems like it's different.
Oh, okay.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Patty is giving us two thumbs up.
Yeah, because we did so well.
Except we're kind of slow, but...
We're exploring.
Okay, it seems like we can do the boss level or we could do...
Oh, Encore.
Tyler?
Uh, Tyler?
Who?
Time Challenges.
Sorry, I meant to say time challenges when I said Tyler.
Yeah, any Tyler's in chat?
I'm thinking about you.
I was...
gonna say who's what but i don't think we would be good at the time challenges i'm not gonna lie yeah wait how do we get to the shop i want to go buy some more faces oh true true true wait so you don't have any jemmies on you it's okay my past self apparently spent them i have 43.
oh wait do you want pyramid heads or do you want do you want a new face or wait it only oh if i pull one for you no no no no you don't have to worry about i feel like i have oh this is like square head and this is rectangle head or you want a circle head no i want to stay triangle oh okay okay here i go do you think it's gonna be cute do you think i'll be cute i think you're always cute but this one's gonna be ugly
Wait, he's so cool!
My bad, my bad, my bad.
He's so cool!
He's cool!
Whoa!
You instantly changed into him.
Oh, he's chilling.
Yeah, I'm sipping my martini.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, you did that.
Yes.
I'm not sorry.
Wait, I might be able to now get some...
a new weapon, actually.
Oh, I can!
Oh!
Wait, so...
I think it's gotcha.
I think it's random.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here I go.
Here you go.
A paper plane.
I got a paper plane.
Uh, I think you'll equip that.
I think it's another bomb.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to equip that.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh!
Oh, I see.
Ah!
So it's deadly.
It first knocks you out.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, it missed.
Oh, are you controlling it?
I don't think so.
I also have to wait, I think, for it to explode.
Oh, that makes sense.
Yeah, I can't, like, spam it.
No, I'm definitely not controlling it.
I'm going to buy another head.
Okay, okay, okay.
I like how the cats are purring.
It's so cute.
Oh, what is that?
That was a mess.
guy I think he was diseased oh god it was just oh my god it's like a zombie oh my gosh oh you can stand on the plane what oh wait really wait it's so fast I can't Maybe I can do it if you throw it.
Okay.
If you throw it, like, yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Get on.
Oh!
I saw you!
I saw it for, like, a second.
Yeah, yeah, you definitely jumped on it.
It's gonna explode.
Somehow, eventually.
Okay.
It'll explode.
Can you control one of them?
Three, two, one.
Explode.
Okay.
It's not exploding.
Push it off the...
There we go.
Uh...
It's...
Oh, maybe I do.
Oh, I detonate it.
Oh.
I can even detonate it in the air.
Oh, my gosh.
This is huge.
Uh-oh.
Whoops.
Whatever.
Hey.
She's just...
Uh-oh.
No, no, no, no.
Look at my face.
I don't look...
No, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Ready for a boss?
Is this a boss?
Or is this the boss?
Yeah, I think this is a boss.
Okay.
Let's go!
Look at us.
Look at us backstage.
Wow.
At our show.
Like, just act natural.
Wait, it's a theater.
That's so cute.
Battle block theater.
Yeah, because we're putting on a show, I think.
Maybe?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh Yeah.
So race against the clock, maybe.
We have to lock it.
Oh, I'm not locking.
I died.
Wait, hold on.
Don't be careful!
Wait!
Yeah, that's a better option.
Oh my gosh, this is...
We only have 40 seconds.
Oh wait, no, we have...
Oh, oh, it adds time.
Oh, okay, good, good.
Okay, we can't fuck it around.
No fucking around.
Oh!
Is the fire burnable?
Okay.
I don't think...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I blew him up!
Oh, my God!
It's working!
Oh, oh, oh!
Well, I'm getting the yarn!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, be careful.
Yeah, be careful.
This music's kind of crazy.
Go, go!
Oh, we have 30 seconds.
We have 30 seconds.
No, we got more.
We'll have to get more.
There we go.
Oh, no, we won't.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Kind of?
Wait, what is this?
Uh, I think...
Wait, is there a secret?
Yes!
I got it!
Oh, there was a secret!
Secret okay okay okay okay.
Wait, okay, okay.
Come here!
Oh, I'm coming!
Okay, okay, okay.
We got more time.
Oh wait, wait, wait.
Oh shoot.
Okay, wait, wait.
There's a gem up there.
Yeah, I know.
Because you get it.
I'm trying.
I got it!
Nice!
Did we get everything?
Oh, nice!
I don't know if we did or not.
Wait, there's a second phase?
What?
There's a second?
What's that a ghost?
It's so cute!
They're upskirting us though.
That's what I do in my 3D all the time.
It's a real true ghost.
Yeah, I'll ghost do that you guys.
Duh.
Wait, there's like a teleporter down here.
Is there?
Oh!
Oh, you got the gem!
Nice!
Wow, I be looking, man.
Yeah, I didn't see that at all.
Okay, nice.
Oh gosh.
I can look at you with my big bug eyes.
Where do we go?
Okay.
Nice.
Not nice.
Oh, go on without me!
Okay.
Bye.
I'm here.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, no worries.
Oh, I killed him.
It's fine.
This has got to be a secret, no?
No, I don't like it.
Okay, just kidding.
Oh, it's just an area to get...
Okay.
Oh, ouch.
My bad.
Oh, why did I do that?
You got it.
Oh, why?
How did you get through?
I just jumped on the thingy.
We jump.
We're jumping.
We're fine.
Oh.
Wait, what?
What is that?
They're spies?
Yeah, but, oh, you just jumped.
Oh.
Hey, you're welcome.
Oh, it's fine.
I made it here.
Yeah.
We have 15 seconds.
Oh, shit.
Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Rindo, I'm dying!
Hurry, hurry, hurry!
I'm going.
I got it Oh, I just ran
Well, wait, what is this?
What is this being torture?
Wow, we're famous Oh, we're famous Wow Look at us Oh, my gosh, I barely You sure know how to make the best I couldn't see anything at the end But boy, this place is quite the enigma Wouldn't you say?
I would And you know, a little warning Would have been nice You know, before they threw us head first And then into this gladiatorial, prison-y place with its perilous medley of twisted stage productions that shred the silky fabric which weaves together the fragile blanket of sanity that keeps us sane.
But, you know, whatever.
Either way, it's safe to say we're in credit- This is very, like, new ground.
Seen us.
Wow, what's happening?
I mean, they do the same for you.
Why is he doing that?
The adventuring just wouldn't be the same without...
I don't know, this guy.
I think this is a good cop, bad cop?
Food so stupid, delicious, one taste would blow your face through the back of your head.
Like bang splat and who could forget this quirky fellow, you know, he owns a bat farm that Oh, his lifelong dream is to breed a terrifying race of super bats None of which makes any sense of course because he's absolutely terrified of bats and this lovely lass always tells the best bedtime stories Oh,
so that's good.
And then there's this guy and this handsome fellow and that Oh, these are friends.
All your best friends in prison.
Why is this the cobra?
They don't like you very much because it's bad and horrible and then there's Hattie the best friend of all why did he stab us in the back and twist the blade I mean just this morning he gave everybody flowers and presents and now he goes out of his way to hurt our feelings oh I think not you can't fool me Hattie would never betray us betray us never betray us something she's going on here and I think I don't like how this seems very one take it must have something yeah albeit fashionable hat sure looks yeah never trust hats glowy red and stuff glowy red stuff So what's dangerous treats lie in store as we continue to unravel this treacherous sweater?
I don't know use caution as you continue your gallant endeavor.
Don't don't like fail and die and stuff because it's- No, we wouldn't.
We wouldn't.
That was scary.
Is he okay?
He's not okay.
I look like I've been through it.
Yeah, you kind of.
Wait, up plus X?
a plus x oh you can now like shove me wait get on my head okay wait oh oh fun okay that's not open so we gotta go through here now we unlock it haddy hadd haddington you strange fellow why haddy why why haddy boy why haddy how many how many jemmies do we have i want we gotta we gotta a new weapon too oh i'm starting to get like new stuff i think i got i got one more yarn oh i got a secret guy like an assassin's creed guy oh wait i got the gravity falls guy oh wait that's true it's mr bill yeah wait he's actually so cute that's pretty good it's pretty cute oh let's see oh i like the Gundam one oh it's a samurai just kidding yeah the samurai
yeah cipher bill cipher yeah bill cipher i need more faces too i'm just Washington wait how many jemmies do you have I don't I have three I think we're starting to get to where maybe i ended i'm not sure oh cute wait it kind of looks like me with my choose your favorite thing and pick your favorite stuff with my thing oh wait true my head that's why i picked the triangle head
i'm rumbling i'm rumbling don't you can't stop me rumbling wait i'm gonna buy one new weapon too okay okay okay okay A grenade.
A grenade.
Just a straight up grenade?
I just got a straight up grenade.
Does it explode immediately?
Let's see.
Why did you aim it at me?
Maybe it just explodes on contact?
Maybe.
No?
Probably like if I...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Throw it at me.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
A grenade!
Let's go!
That'll be ears I have.
I'm hearing her.
You're such a good listener, Barry.
I know.
I am listening.
All I can do is listen.
Oh, watch out.
He kind of looks like a Domo.
Oh, I know what you're talking about.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna throw the grenade.
Okay, okay.
Okay, hold on.
I'm not gonna miss.
Okay.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I'm not gonna miss.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
Well, you didn't miss.
I didn't miss.
Wait.
Oh.
How do you...
Yeah, I'll kick his ass.
I'm throwing grenades.
I'm getting him.
I'm helping.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
You're helping.
Maybe if I throw it from this angle.
Oh, he's gone.
No, I already killed him.
How do you get over?
Oh, it's probably...
We got it.
You got him?
Oh.
No, I didn't.
So close.
You're so close.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, I got it.
I helped.
Yeah, you helped.
You helped.
And I died.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I'm up here.
Oh, be careful.
Be careful.
There you go.
Nice.
Okay, okay, nice.
Okay, wait, let me throw you.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, throw me.
Throw me.
Okay, I'm going.
Okay, I'm dying.
You didn't die?
You didn't die!
I didn't die!
Oh, what the...
Huh?
Hello?
Man, that's my breakfast.
I missed.
Now we have soggy toes.
Oh, shit.
Stop it.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, okay, I'll quit it, I quit.
Wait, I'm st- I'm getting- I'm getting bullied!
Wait, wait, wait wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
Don't do that!
Why are they so advanced?
How do we- Issues is over here?
Hey, chill out, man.
Why did we miss something down there?
Hey, ah- I'm trying to get the toast!
I'm trying to get the toast!
Okay, oh okay, oh just- I'm doing that!
Yeah, how do we get the yarn?
I think we have to go back.
Hmm.
Hold on.
I'm going.
Wait.
No, maybe?
Um.
Oh, wait.
I think so.
I think you're supposed to like, uh...
Oh, from right there.
I don't know.
No, you're right.
You're right.
I think.
I think, I think, uh...
Yeah.
So from here, I like...
I...
Oh, whoops.
I throw you up there using the thingy.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Uh...
Oh.
it oh wrong way oh wait no no no no no you we do the this thing oh yeah you're right yeah like that okay we're good oh yeah see we got it we're gamers we never forget our yarn are you what our yarn oh yeah the yarn is so important what do you think i said i i don't know actually oh why thank you there you go
it's fine oh yeah oh wait i'm here now thank you there you go okay now kill the toast oh oh you're toast you're toast you're toast you're toast i think you can ignore the toast yeah i think it's fine oh they get they get toasted from the laser oh that's cute i get it uh okay that thing kills apparently oh ouch it does not apparently like actually yeah yeah Yeah,
yeah.
It does 100%.
Absolutely.
1000%.
Wow!
Oh, wait.
Is this everything?
Oh, Jesus.
I think that's everything, yeah.
I think so too.
There's seven of them.
All right.
Four, five, six, seven.
It was easy.
Now imagine if we were faster.
Got that time bonus.
It's okay.
Life is meant to be...
Enjoyed at your pace.
Oh,
I guess there's another one.
Oh, I got a gemmy.
Oh, wait, good job.
What the heck?
I didn't even realize.
I'm gaming unintentionally.
Oh, I got another one.
Oh, okay, okay.
You're dying?
She's carrying me.
Maybe don't come in here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, wait, no, I think you are supposed to go in there.
I got it.
Okay.
I think I go up through here.
Okay, cool.
Oh, don't me too.
Okay, very good.
Easy.
Easy peasy.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There's a, there's a, there's a, oh, wait.
What the?
A golden hat has appeared.
Bring it to the exit and I'll make it rain.
Wait, make it to the exit and I'll make it rain.
What?
Really?
What is this?
the hat.
I got it.
Oh, I, you know, I think that the hat thing is, is play, it's like player side.
So only you and I can have it, but not both of us.
Oh, oh, I hope I don't die.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, okay.
I'm fine.
Everything's fine.
Wait, where'd the hat go?
Uh, I think it got the, it just got deleted from the, I think you still have it.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Me, me, me, me.
What?
No!
I have it!
I'm going to try to kill you.
What if I wanted the hat?
Well, you can get a next time.
Jeez, slow poke.
I'm sorry I just didn't sniff out the freaking secret.
Like, something.
I bet you cheated.
What?
I'm a cheater.
I'm not a cheater.
But I am a pumpkin eater.
I'll admit that.
Oh.
I'm stuck.
Oh, wait, what the hell?
There, I'm better now.
We're fine.
I got the yarn up there.
Okay.
You got this?
I got it.
Is there anything up here?
Wait, hold on.
The next thing?
I don't think so.
Oh, I don't think so, yeah.
Be careful.
Oh, wait.
There's a...
Oh, there's a...
Boop, boop, boop.
Boop, boop.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, nice!
Thanks.
I actually got him.
I am a gamer.
You're gaming, you're gaming.
No chicken hat for you, you're gaming.
No, I like the chicken hat, actually.
I think it's pretty cute.
That sounds like cope to me, though.
What?
No.
I don't know.
Wait, what's down here?
What's down here?
Oh, I came from down there.
Oh, you did?
Okay, just kidding.
Yeah, yeah.
I think the chicken has cute.
Oh.
He's not a chicken, he's a snake.
Yeah, but it's so, it lights up and it's so cute and they laugh at you.
Oh, it lights up, really?
Yeah.
It really make it obvious, huh?
Wait!
Thank you!
Oh, it's this guy again.
Oh.
Wait, I was sorry.
I'll blow him up.
Or you will.
Yeah, I got him.
You gamed?
Sorry, I just really wanted to kill.
What the?
Oh, ouch, I died.
Wait, no, take me back!
Oh, wait, wait, I got it, I got it!
Oh, wait, but there's more!
Yeah, there's a lot more, actually, we haven't gotten.
Yeah.
Ah, wait, I hit myself.
I got him.
Okay, nice.
I think we got both of them.
Right?
Is that not everything?
Yeah, that is.
You're right.
Okay.
Unless you're the secret.
I think we're good.
Oh, why did you do that?
Oh, wait, that's me.
Oh, someone said he's not a crocodile either, but he wears a crocodile hat.
But that's because he's camouflaged.
The chicken is not camouflaged.
The chicken's not camouflaged!
It sounds like cop!
Wow, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
That's not cop!
Let's go.
I guess it is true that he's cropped up.
I love the croc hat.
Why is he so like crazy for the gems?
Because that's money.
Money, money, baby.
Wait, do you have the money toggle?
The... the...
What?
I don't have that!
Oh, damn.
Minto needs an update.
Wait, what are these guys for?
Uh...
I actually don't know.
just to like stop them i don't know actually there's nothing here oh i'm stuck you're fine oh wait no we probably we oh we probably oh no no oh you can jump with it oh okay wait what is that i have no money everybody i i have no money i am poor i mean poor i've been given no money oh that's white water okay oh wait it's definitely blue water Oh wait,
you could bring it!
You could bring it!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, and then they start going through too!
These guys!
Oh, sorry, I pushed you down.
Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh.
Uh oh.
Okay, I'll put it here.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, wait, I'm not...
It's my brain!
Okay, alright, we're fine.
We got this.
Well, we're...
Well, I understand now.
I understand now.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, wait, hold on.
I think we do need it though, no?
Or do we just use these guys?
No, I think we just use the Domo guys.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I gotta wait for him to come back.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Oh.
Interesting.
Oh, watch out!
So close.
We're gaming.
Well, that's definitely a secret.
Yeah, that's definitely a secret.
We know now.
We're just so smart.
Oh, I missed.
It's okay.
We got it.
You got it.
No, go back there.
Wait, wait, wait, don't throw your grenade at me.
Uh-huh.
Okay, you got this block puzzle.
Yeah, it's a block.
Yeah!
I'm so smart.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Oh, it's that thing again.
Oh, wait, wait, I have to go back.
Move!
Ah, wait!
Is he a friend or a foe?
I think he's friend.
Did he try to kill him?
I don't know if we can even...
Maybe he leads us to somewhere.
Wait, jump on my shoulders?
Okay.
Go up there?
Oh, go up there.
There you go.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, come up here, come up here.
I will get you up here.
I'm coming.
There you go.
Okay.
Wait, uh, uh, okay, maybe you get off of the thing.
And then...
Oh!
What just happened?
What is that?
Oh, a secret!
Wait, this music is crazy.
Stop it even out of...
Oh, wait, what's going on?
Oh my god Oh no, I didn't need to leave I'm so sorry I think, I think No, no, no, I think we got everything I think we got it Yeah, I think we got everything Oh, oh, oh my Oh, so the shrimp are secret Like they let you know that there's a secret in the level Oh,
that makes sense We've seen a shrimp before though And we haven't Wait, but we didn't get to beat the level I don't think Oh, we got the time Oh my god, we get extra gems for that oh dang okay wait time to go gotcha pulling i'm obsessed with this you guys can't stop ew okay why do you keep doing the pyramids because it's it's me oh that's cute it's like too hard yeah oh detective detective oh god oh it would have been been cute over the face wait oh my gosh dang oh my god oh my god that's him with the with the goggles yeah why did you wow wait i i should probably switch to let's see to george washington yeah george was iconic what am i getting what did i get and i'm oticon
That kind of works.
Oh my god, ice.
Wait, what does this do?
Whoa.
Here, I'll get hit by it.
Oh, me too.
That's funny.
I don't think that's great.
Snake?
Snake!
I only heard you explode.
I did not witness this.
so guys it's not splinter cell it's definitely ground zero snake okay shut up yeah thermal goggles you guys thermal goggles okay night vision goggles yeah totally totally i think we have to redo this one oh do we okay yeah okay we got a bee oh yeah i think that was oh wait i don't know
I don't know, man.
My saved five...
When I was, like, a teenager and played this game, it's fucking us up, man.
Why?
I'm sorry.
Because, uh, it's like...
It's like...
Telling us that we've completed levels that we didn't complete.
No, it's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, snake!
Yeah?
Oh, my God, we can act out our fanfiction.
I'm too much of a gamer.
You're gaming, you're gaming.
Oh, why the hell did I get all the way back here?
Oh, sorry.
That might have been because of me.
Oh, it's okay.
Ah!
You're fine.
We're good.
I saved your life.
Your head saved me.
Oh, damn it.
Snake?
Snake!
Oh, God.
You're fine.
I'm the puzzle guy.
You're the puzzle guy.
We're puzzle guys.
Of course we...
Okay.
Of course we solve puzzles.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Why did I do that?
Oh, we could actually talk about this, but...
Yeah, I guess like, IRL we've met up, like, a couple of times.
Because we also met up during the Delta pop-up, right?
Yeah!
Yeah, and then he walked all the way to fucking, like, Liberty, whatever, to, to, to, like, a pilgrimage, the, where, where I didn't know.
Yeah, Federal Hall, that's what it's called.
Sorry, I had no idea what it was.
I just recognized it.
I did.
Yeah, I was like, I gotta go see it.
I gotta go see my president.
Dude, she...
Meant is crazy, because she, like, pulled out, like, the solidest, like, action figure.
out of her, like, backpack snows.
It was crazy.
I brought all my toys.
All your toys.
I only brought my little guy.
It was, it's my, I don't ever go to New York.
It's my chance.
Yeah, but I guess that's true.
Maybe, maybe I should have brought my ride in Nendo.
Oh, yeah, it would have been good.
Yeah, the little guy, though, The one from the...
Oh, what is this?
What is this?
What's going on here?
The one from the gotcha...
Gotcha machine.
Yeah, I know.
The little guy.
Yeah, the little guy.
Someone in chat didn't...
Someone in chat didn't.
Oh, they will know.
They will know.
Are you good?
Okay, I'm just gonna self-destruct.
Oh!
What's this?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Be careful.
Oh, wait.
What?
You weren't careful?
Uh, no.
I was totally careful.
Okay.
I'm always careful.
Oh!
Oh, wait.
I didn't notice.
Oh!
Oh, can you just walk?
Oh, wait.
No, you can't.
Oh.
You gotta walk onto the next guy.
yeah it's fine come here little boat oh the boats over there oh oh that was close oh yeah I heard the sound effect come here come here come here come on Barry I wanted to I wanted to prevent you from getting in
Don't get your ass out of my face!
I'm killing him.
Oh, he died himself.
Yeah, he...
Oh, gosh.
Be careful!
She's killing me, you guys.
She's bullying.
I did nothing.
That was all me.
This is payback for a...
Five is a good number, bit.
What?
I think it was like something like, oh, five is a good number and you were just like, do you just say anything?
Wait, we're missing one.
Are we?
Oh, wait, you might be right.
Yeah, because it's supposed to be seven.
No, that's not it.
During the lore game, yeah.
Dude, I have to visit you sometime and so I can play PT at your house.
Yay!
Come visit me!
Ah, no stop!
You're like the only person...
You're like the last person with Flappy Bird on their phone.
Yeah!
Someone said we got it all, are we sure?
Oh, you... baby?
Yeah, October is coming up.
Oh, we did!
Nice!
Did we get the time?
We did get the time?
Yeah, we were just standing there talking.
Who needs time?
Yeah, who needs time?
Oh, maybe you can...
Yeah, block them, block them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Minecraft them, Minecraft them.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, get him.
Wait, it's mine.
It's mine.
Stop, stop, stop.
We're not even there yet, are we?
It's mine.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You make that dream, Carol.
Make it.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh no!
Why did the game punish me?
Oh, oops.
Oopsie.
Wait, huh?
Wait, why didn't it go?
You gotta pull it.
I'm pulling it though.
You're doing it?
Yeah, you are.
Wait, why?
Why isn't it?
Wait, hold on.
I'm so weak.
There we go.
Wait, I'm so weak.
Can you call it over?
Huh?
Wait, why isn't it going on?
I have no sexual appeal.
Let me try.
Okay.
Let a real man do it.
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, what the...
Wait, that's so BS.
What does that mean?
What did they mean?
I don't know.
That has to be a glitch, right?
No.
I mean...
That has to be a glitch.
The game said what the game says.
I...
What are you...
The game said?
What the game?
Oh, you made it somehow.
I made it.
Wait, isn't the hat like somewhere here?
The hat is at the end.
Oh, maybe... Oh, you think so?
Yeah, he says it's at the end.
Oh!
Why didn't it drop?
It's just floating.
Can you say to bring it to the end?
Oh, I don't know, actually.
Oh.
Wait, what am I doing?
I don't know.
Oh, oh, oh, block it, block it.
Ah, I'm working on it.
Oh, close, close.
Okay.
No, oh.
Okay, okay.
Like that.
There you go.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's my controls.
My controls aren't working.
She's playing with tilt controls.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I think we went...
No, no, no, no, no!
But I think we went the wrong way.
We left stuff over there.
Yeah, I know.
I just wanted to...
Grab something, you know?
I wanted to grab something real quick.
Ah!
No!
You...
Very bug.
No, no, no, no.
No!
Oh, dang it!
Oh my god!
Wait, where did it go?
It went, Barry.
I think we lost it.
Wait, it went into the water.
Did we lose it?
I think we lost.
Oh my god.
Our greed.
Our greed has destroyed us.
It has.
No, I'll go in for it.
I'll go in for it.
Our greed has destroyed us.
Why did this happen?
No, I don't want to live anymore.
I don't want to live anymore.
Maybe a respawn...
Maybe a respawn back here.
Oh, true, true, true.
No, it didn't.
That was absolute copium, but that's okay.
I was here for it.
Oh, dang it.
Maybe the real moral of the story is that we should work together.
Because if one of us wins, all of us wins.
Uh-huh.
Why do you sound like that?
Maybe the real winners wore the hags we thrust it along.
No, that's not.
What?
Sorry, I have a regular in my chat called Hags We Thrust Along the Way.
And he used to be called Friends We Made Along the Way.
But then he got really obsessed with hags.
And he used to always say maybe the real blank was the friends we made along the way.
But now he's, since he's hags, he always says maybe the real blank was the we thrust it along the way not me one of my chatters you played meat and fuck kingdom i don't want to hear anything from you don't give me that look don't give me that look oh oh oh i think you need to find some little sparkly gem shaped shapes let's find the gems find the gems oh you got it you got Quiz
There you go.
Oh, and then you go...
I'll get it.
I go on it.
And then I trap.
Okay.
No, I don't trap you.
No.
I was just kidding.
You were trying to trap me.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I was kidding.
Are you gonna get that guy?
Nice.
Oh, oh, I got him!
Okay.
Woohoo!
Oh, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Ow, ow, ow.
Whoa, whoa.
You're okay, stop whining.
What do you mean?
You make the same exact noises too.
Guys, I think berry bugs are berry babies.
What?
Guys, you don't know when Mint's.
Where are you?
I'm over here.
I don't know how.
Oh, there we go.
When Mint, Mint dropped one of her snacks in the hotel and then she was so, It was so sad she put her face in my boobies.
That's why I put my face in her boobies.
Because I dropped my snack and I was sad.
She's a baby.
She's a baby too.
Don't let her tell you otherwise.
I was like, family, I'm so sad.
Please let me put my face in your boobs.
She's a freak.
him wait how do you get that so oh i guess we maybe throw oh i'm trying to get up hold on i'm trying there you go i died but it was worth it yeah it was worth it oh what the heck was that oh ice oh you got it nice oh it's these guys that's a lot of that's a lot of ice it's okay i killed the other you killed me uh do you think we got all of them there's so many i think so i think so too oh i don't think there's like oh my god how did i live oh i'm here there you go yeah
well we didn't tell them about like the the cup of jelly that we were communally eating from
like the starbucks uh stirs as like chopsticks yeah and then there was like someone gave me some jellies and i just was eating them we were all like just eating them from a cup in the in the hotel room yeah i'm stuck i'm stuck no you're not okay i'm not a thing is trying to kill us wait i think you can lift it up oh yeah can't i don't think I don't think so.
Okay.
Oh.
We're fine.
Nice.
Oh.
Go that way.
I'm trying.
Oh, I got it.
Okay.
Good job.
There's a...
Oh, is this a...
Oh!
Nice catch.
Okay, that's good.
Yeah.
Wait, but how do we get...
Oh, it's a teleporter.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
Oh, oops, I did that too.
That was karma.
Oh my gosh.
You got this?
Okay, you got it.
Okay, nice.
I got it.
Here, I'll help you.
I'll help you.
We're team working!
Yeah, we're team.
We're team.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to keep an eye out for the...
Wait, what about that teleporter?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe this way?
Oh my god.
Oh!
You left me the die!
Sorry, I didn't want to...
I didn't want to...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Shit.
Nah, I think he gets ya.
Yeah.
Well, where was the teleport?
If I were a teleporter...
Yeah, if I were a teleporter...
Okay, you can come over.
Oh!
Yours extends it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oops.
Don't mind me.
You were a teleporter.
If I were a teleporter...
I would.
I killed a man.
I killed a man and I'll do it again.
I did it twice.
Why did you do such a thing?
Where's the teleporter?
Is it somehow...
I don't know.
Oh,
you just said be careful, Barry.
Oh, I told you.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Was it me?
Did you say you'd be careful, Mince?
Oh, maybe we bugged.
Maybe we bugged.
Can we blow these up?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Is there...
Is a teleporter over here?
No, we can't blow them up.
Ah!
So sad.
It's homing.
I don't think it's homing, but...
Oh, whoopsie.
He just knows where I am.
Oh, you got it.
There you go.
You got him.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
We're both ready.
He's coming.
Coming.
How dare you?
And you're gonna get the yarn.
Ah!
Wait, where is it?
Where, where, where, where, where, where is it?
Where is it, where is it?
Oh, God, I don't.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, I mean, wait, I thought we were in this together.
Hold on, come back.
Are we?
Hold on, hold on.
Wait, I don't know if we can get back up.
Oh yeah, we can do anything we set our minds to.
Oh gosh.
Maybe.
Uh.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Uh, uh.
Oh, wait, it's not there!
No!
Vinton!
Yes, yes, me?
Ah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
Oh!
You said next time I will get it.
Don't be so.
You killed me.
You killed me, very bad.
It was just two.
Okay, you can get it next time, I promise.
I promise.
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
I should probably have done this.
Nah, it's okay.
I got it.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Just don't trap me in there.
I was jumping up.
No, I got the gemmy already.
Oh.
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
So he's going to start running.
Go.
Get him, get him, get him, get him.
Oh.
Nice.
I guess we don't, we don't, we don't do that.
You are so close.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't have to deal with this.
Fine.
And...
Okay, let me...
Lift me!
I'm getting you!
Be careful.
Oh wait, we can get...
Pull up more though.
Yeah.
Or maybe I launch you?
Launch me.
Oh, launch me.
Nice!
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm good.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nice.
We're fine.
I'll stand here.
Okay.
Okay, I think that should be good.
Yeah, I think so.
There we go, nice.
Oh my God.
Okay, we're fine.
This is fine.
Everything is fine.
Don't stress.
Stop stressing.
I'm not stressing.
You're stressing.
I'm so smooth.
Someone is trying to kill us.
Oh, you're right.
Ah.
Oh.
I tried to, hold on.
Yeah, he has a teleporter behind him.
Ah!
Okay, what is that?
Oh!
It's a shortcut.
That's kind of handy.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh, throw me.
Okay, I'm throwing you.
Nice.
How do I get over there now?
Um...
Oh!
Wait.
That way.
I...
Wait, I'll throw you.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, don't miss.
Okay, I'm not missing.
Okay, nice, nice.
There you go.
Okay, easy peasy.
We're working together.
I'll hold it.
All right, I'm going.
I'm leaving.
I'm holding it.
Okay, all right, ready?
Okay, I think you dropped me.
Yeah.
Okay, now you go.
Nice.
Wait.
Is there anything behind him?
I was just about to check, yeah.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Nothing behind him.
Okay, we're good.
We're safe.
We're good.
Nice.
Yeah, cover that.
Anything?
Nothing behind me.
Oh.
Nice!
Gaming?
How do we, uh...
I guess we throw you, maybe?
Throw me!
Maybe we do the...
I throw you?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I throw you.
Maybe like up, up, up X.
Wait, hold on.
Try this side?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, wait.
You might have to...
Up X.
Oh, yeah.
What the heck?
Wait, what is that?
I don't know.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, nice.
Oh, he says all complete.
Yeah, he does.
What is that?
Help, help.
There you go.
I made it.
How do I get up there?
Wait, how do you get up there?
Oh, I probably just...
Wait, no.
Wait.
You're fine.
I just came?
Okay, yeah!
Poo-poo-poo!
Poo-poo!
If there's not another one, I gotta go get some water real quick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it sounds good.
Yeah.
Here we come, please.
Yeah, I think the boss is there.
Go get water.
Okay, I'll go get water real quick.
Okay, go get water.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Okay.
Hi.
Don't say ew.
What the freak?
I can't see Minto's chat right now, but I bet all of you wisps are being so nice to me.
You're like, wow, Berrybug, we love you, Berrybug.
Wow.
I love the Bento collab.
I love Berrybug.
And I want to give Berrybug all my money and mint all my money as well.
But also Berrybug my money.
yeah yeah it's the lunchbox collab I'm trying to think of other cute names because you got the gay collab that mint and the green and yellow women gay is just so good thank you for thank you for the money after stream or after collab I'll be sure to thank everybody
I'm trying to think I guess it is just bento, huh?
Like, berry and minto?
Uh, but then, thank you for...
Thank you.
Bent color.
Get bent!
I'm not a creep!
Do I look like a damn creep to you?
Huh?
Do I look like a damn creep?
Hi.
What?
Your chat...
Your whispers are calling me a creep.
Why?
I know.
I can't believe it.
What'd you do?
I didn't do anything.
Why would you assume that I did anything?
What'd you do?
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Why?
Oh, no, I didn't mean to go in there!
Oopsie.
Oh, my God, we're back in the fucking...
I'm going in here.
Yeah, yeah, do that.
Do that instead.
Okay, good job, Dota.
Okay, okay.
Are they cheering for us?
Yeah, they love us.
They love us.
Oh, I love you.
We have to lock in because they're timed.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, what's this over here?
Wait, how do we...
Oh, you did it.
Okay, that's how.
Thank you for the dono!
Wait, I'll be sure...
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
I'll be sure to thank everybody after a while, but thank you.
Thank you!
Thank you guys!
Oh, God, oh God.
Oh my God.
Oh, my God.
I can't tell anything that's happening right now.
Okay, I got us extra time.
Okay, okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
No, not nice, not nice, not nice.
Is it nice?
I'm fine.
Oh, there's the yarn!
There's the yarn!
Wait, how do we get that?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Come, come to me.
Ouch.
Nope.
Who's spitting at us?
Oh.
Got him?
There you go.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Why can't I get through the...
Ah!
There we go.
Okay.
You have to go up here.
And then you have to go through here.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Oh!
Okay, don't jump.
Don't jump.
Oh, don't, I don't.
That's fine.
We made it.
Oh, don't go.
Don't jump again.
Yeah, don't stop again.
Oh, except.
Okay, nice.
Stop believing.
Okay, okay.
Hang on to that.
Beel.
Oh, hang on to that.
Oh, me too, I died.
Oh, ow, ow, ow, tail.
It's terrible, man.
Oh my god, stop, please!
Marcy, Marcy!
Marcy!
Use my head.
There you go.
I'll go over here.
Oh, and then maybe...
Oh!
Oh, dang it!
I did not mean to do...
No, no, no!
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Okay.
I'm sure it's fine.
All right.
Oh, oops.
Oh, oh.
Oh, please, please, let me in.
I got it.
You got this, Minto.
You got this.
I'll get it.
How'd you get there?
I just went on the log.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Whoa!
What's going on?
Everything's so fast!
Where am I?
Oh, I'm in the water.
What happened?
Hello, girl.
I am under the water.
Yeah, the yarn is there.
I don't know if we can...
We think it's so fast.
I don't think we get it right there anyway.
Oh, you think so?
I don't think so.
Nice, good job.
Oh, wait, you're right, you're right, you're right.
Okay, then how do we...
How do we?
Oh, I guess we probably go...
Oh, yeah.
We probably go here.
Okay.
There is...
Oh, oopsie.
Bye-bye.
There's nothing here.
It's okay.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
That's actually fine.
Okay, it's actually fine.
Oh, oh, oh, we're stuck.
Okay, they're not going...
Okay.
We're fine.
I think there's a...
There is a secret.
Okay, I got it.
It's okay.
You got it?
Nice.
Why did you spawn there?
I don't know?
The game hates me.
I don't know, the game hates me?
Wait, I got it!
Wait!
I didn't want to get it without you.
It's okay.
Just get it, just get it.
What is that?
It's the key.
It's the... To unlock next the...
Oh my... Oh my God.
We're so tall.
Yeah, we're so tall.
I guess maybe we missed a thingy.
Standing applause!
Yippee!
Chapter complete.
Way to bite the bullet so far.
Hell yeah.
The prison food, which is shopping because that stuff tastes like doo-doo casserole with the side of butt salad.
But rest of all, your riveting performances have the theater bursting at the seams with excited patrons.
And with all this extra cash you're making.
Yeah.
and really start beefing up these horrifying shows of murdery death to appease the fickle crowd so so that's good and what's the deal with hatty he just creepily looms around the theater all day look at him oh my god he's like seems like he's been forcefully forced he's like wasting away looks that way he just sort of sits there is he okay productive as one can be he's crying living life to the fullest whoa slow down my god yes sir full of salt and pepper with youthful energy say something hatty what the cat got your tongue shut up yeah he might just be dead he could be yeah strange part of the world i don't think he's okay was a delicious gift from the heavens gods and these bizarre cats are taking full advantage of us what cruel fate i like the cat people the grounds of this scary yeah they're cute desperately ruling these bleak premises with an iron paw and just how long have they been orchestrating this sinister scheme i mean the avert them there's bony people skeletons everywhere
scary right now i'm no genius but i definitely know how long it takes for a body to decompose this must have been going on for at least wait scratch that thing i said so do you possess the courage the soldier onward and uncover the mysterious we possess courage or will your hilarious death screams be drowned out by the sound of your We shall see.
That's us.
We shall see.
No, we're cooler.
We're better than that.
Yeah, we're so good at this game.
Oh, three and four.
Oh.
There's a potty up there.
Oh, yeah.
I think this is where my old self stopped playing the game because mine only goes to like a little bit of it.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la I wanna see You can use the urinal
Have you ever wanted to pee standing up though?
Yeah, I want to try.
Yeah, I think it would be so much...
Can I do more gotcha?
It would make...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like it would make you feel powerful though.
If you like put your hands on your hips like in a really assertive way.
Ew!
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, like a rhino, I see.
Oh, that one's kind of cute.
That one's kind of cute.
I keep getting sports cam.
Oh.
Ew, what is that?
What is that?
Cool guy.
Oh, this is cool.
That's Bojo.
One more.
Oh, Bojo.
Okay, I'm going to go get a new weapon too.
Oh, hell yeah.
close to getting more stuff good what the hell is that the kamehameha aha stop jumping roll that's fine i like that one yeah you're you're uh i guess that's the will of a whisk yeah oh oh my god the screams are crazy Jesus
That's what you're making me do, man That's what Wait, is it?
Is it this?
Yeah, it's this Oh, okay And we go How do I You should try it You should do If you ever want to play flash games again There's like a Archive of them That you can download And it has like Every flash game Oh, really?
Yeah, I was like I was even looking up like really weird Korean flash games that I used to play on a Korean website and they even had those.
Oh, nice.
Wait, it says go up.
Hold on, I'll lift you, I'll lift you.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry, sorry.
Oh, lift me.
Okay.
Okay, all right.
Then how do, how do, oh, like you do, uh, there we go.
Wow.
Multiplayer flash.
You gotta, you gotta get me up.
Oh, wait, there was a thing there.
That'd be fun.
I'd be curious to see, like...
I think there's, like, that one Japanese flash game where you have to play a guy who's, like, avoiding kisses or something.
What?
Also, wait, there's some more stuff we missed.
Oh, there's a thing there.
Oh, you got it.
Um, there's also...
We didn't go the other way.
I just immediately went through the...
Oops.
I died.
I don't think we can go the other way.
Was there not another way?
No, we started off like that.
Oh, you're right.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, blow yourself up.
I will.
Oh, I'll go this way.
Or I'll die and then respawn.
That's the better option.
More time-efficient option.
Get me up there.
I'm not pulling all this weight.
Wait, I think you have to...
Push me!
How?
Get over there!
I think you have to...
Oh, not like that, but I think you have to...
Okay, this way.
There you go.
Oh, I turned it off.
Oh, okay.
Oh, you got a...
Oh, you turned it off permanently.
Yeah.
Oh.
Ouch.
Help me.
Oh my god.
You go.
Oh.
See?
I'm a team player.
Team player.
Oh, I forgot to...
Oops.
Ah!
I forgot to...
Okay.
Here you go, here you go.
Thank you.
All right.
Okay.
I'm crawling down like a doll.
Like a damn dog.
Oh, oopsie.
Don't go that way.
Oh, here I'll let you go.
There you go.
Oh, dang.
Oh, what is this?
Uh oh.
Easy.
Just complete silence while we were doing that.
Oops.
Oh, you did it.
That was me.
Hey!
Oh, sorry.
I'm trying to get you up there because there's a...
Oh, there's one on the other side too.
So...
Okay, okay.
And...
Wait.
How do I do it?
Oh, it's X.
Oh, my bad.
Try again.
Okay.
Wait, but there's like more.
There is?
I feel...
Oh, wait, because we get angel wings.
The thing is over here!
Oh, you got it!
I got it!
I got it.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm blowing myself up.
Going?
This, what does this do?
Oh, I have to remove it.
Get off of the thing?
There you go.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh, wait, but I...
Now, but now...
I have to get the...
Oh, I think...
Yeah, yeah, I think you have to get rid of it.
Yeah, like that.
You just have to time it.
Easy.
Easy mode.
Did we get everything?
Okay.
Got the yarn?
It's seven?
Is there any secrets like up here?
We didn't see any any little.
I think we're good.
I think so too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Surely there wouldn't be Week, right?
You think?
I don't think so.
Nah, we're good.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tuxedo happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, Saiyutai Shots.
I always forget the melody of the Metal Gear ones.
Have you ever listened to it on your birthday?
I always do, or for the past two years I have, but...
It's good.
I just like...
I just am terrible at remembering melodies.
There you go.
Very good.
Happy birthday.
Oh, oh.
Ah, yo!
Oh, hold on.
I'll shoot him.
Oh, okay.
I think you got him, though.
You got him.
I did?
Oh, yeah.
Because he's not standing on it anymore.
Yeah.
Wait, but how do we get over the...
Oh, there you go.
I think we just...
Yeah.
Oh, that's it.
Wait.
I won't get it.
I'll get it.
Actually, launch me, yeah.
Yeah, I'm launching.
Okay.
Oh, I turned him off.
There you go.
Okay, nice.
I turn him back on.
I turn him off.
Oh, wait.
Wait, what's this over here?
I don't know.
Oh, wait, wait.
There is some...
Yeah, there's a gem.
Oh, wait.
There...
How do we get this?
Can you stand on my head, maybe?
Yes.
Okay.
And then...
Oh.
Is that...
Uh...
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, stay there.
Yeah, I'm saying.
I'm saying.
I'm what?
Oh, there's the bird wings.
There's...
There's a...
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Oopsie.
Uh-oh.
Bye-bye.
I got you.
I'm fine.
I don't need no help.
Wait.
Oh, thank you.
You're welcome.
No, no.
Oh, wait, wait.
But there's a...
I think there's a secret.
Oh, wait.
No, maybe not.
You're gonna get crushed.
Oh, just kidding.
Wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, I thought...
Yeah, I think it's from the bottom.
I think it's from the bottom.
Oh.
Well, how do you do it from the bottom?
Oh, the wings.
Red bull.
Gives you wings.
Oh, give you wings.
I missed all of them.
You did the same thing.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah.
I can't get back up.
Thank you.
Wait, hold on.
Let me try if I go here.
Oh, big grin, bad.
Oh, my God.
She is so smart.
I'm so smart.
How's that for a bugbrain?
Heck yeah.
She's so smart.
Wait, what's over this way?
I'm so smart and awesome and beautiful and...
I don't think I can go this way.
Yeah, I think I need to go this way.
Hmm.
No, because we turned off the thingies.
Do we need the...
No, the wings again maybe?
Oh, maybe.
like you oh i think so actually maybe not okay go get him go get him i'll get him go get him okay nice come over here baby okay be careful okay okay it's okay you're you're there okay go go go go go yeah oh okay nice even better okay Okay.
Oh, that's fine.
It's okay.
Worthy sacrifice.
Oops.
Why did I jump?
Okay.
Oh.
There's a...
Oh my god.
That was a crazy scream.
Wait.
I feel like there's something in there.
Yeah, right?
Oh.
Where did you go?
Oh, oh, oh, I'm down here.
Get him, get him.
Oh, yeah.
I feel like there's something in here.
Okay.
Oh, there's nothing in there.
No, maybe.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, oh, we got rid of the thing over here.
Yeah, yeah, this was blocking the way up.
Orange arch.
Connecting it in my brain.
Oops.
Oh, I should have a lot of guys.
Nice.
Oh, wait, you're on fire.
I'm also on fire.
It's okay.
It was okay.
Now take it off.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think we got one of them.
I think so too!
Yippee!
Holy, we're so freaking good at this game.
This game's so easy.
Don't look at the time.
This is my first time playing.
So it's impossible to speedrun something you've never played before.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, my bad.
My bad.
I was just checking for any secrets that way.
Yeah, no, don't worry.
I get it.
Uh, I'm here.
Oh, you got it.
Oh, we have to go here.
Nice.
Oh.
I think, um, maybe I drag it.
I think I can, I can, I can go on your head, I think.
Come on.
If you, if you, if you put me up there, do like, uh, if you do the...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, do the...
Oh!
There you go.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Okay.
And then here.
And now you can push it off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, true.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Now you can get it.
And then you can come here.
I'll come.
Oh, no, I'll come.
No, oh, oh, oh, I can't control this boat.
Oh, wait, don't do that.
Don't do that.
The boat's made on paper.
Paper.
See, we're, we're...
Oh, oops, sorry.
Oh, okay.
One at a time.
Be careful.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Yeah, don't do what I did.
My mistake.
That don't do that.
Whoa!
I got it.
Set it on fire.
Can he die?
Maybe?
Ah!
Oh, he might be, like, invincible, actually.
I don't think so.
I'll get it.
Okay, you got it.
You got it.
Oh, I see what?
You actually got it.
Okay.
There you go.
Wait.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oopsie.
He's used my body.
Nice.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we did it.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, one more time.
Oh, watch out!
Oh!
He got me too!
I was pretty fucked up.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I didn't even grab on.
I think you got what you wanted.
What did I get?
I don't know anything about that.
Oh, the gem, the gem.
Yeah, yeah, I got the gemmy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just trying to make it.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
I'll die.
There we go.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's fine.
You'll live.
What the heck?
What's up?
Was that all of them?
Oh, I didn't even need to do that.
What the hell?
It was the secret!
You know, Minko, you know what's funny about every time we collab?
Every time we collab, it's one inch closer to a Roblox collab.
I'll get you someday.
How do you figure that?
The more we hang out, the more we...
I can brainwash you into being like, oh, maybe the games that Barry recommends are so bad.
And then one day that'll be it'll be like a conditioning.
Well, this is the first game you've recommended.
That's true.
But we're slowly getting to it.
Oh my god.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What's going on in here?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I killed.
Oh my god.
Is there like a secret in here though?
I feel like there must be.
right?
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait, everyone's dead now.
Yeah, you think Minto would like dress to impress?
Maybe.
Watch out.
Okay.
Good job.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, why did I do that?
To be honest, I feel like Roblox games have gone down in qualities.
Why do you think that?
Because a lot of them are just a lot of them are just like Like rehashes of, like, popular games.
Uh, boo.
Yeah.
Wooa!
Oops.
Why did she do that?
Why did I do that?
Why did she do that, you guys?
Oh, I got another gem.
Oh, okay.
And I killed a man.
I'm going to move this.
You killed a man.
Mama.
I
want to go, yeah, the other way.
Oh yeah, there's a yarn.
Get the yarn.
Okay, come over here.
Come here.
Oh, I was so close.
You were close.
I was so close.
All right, here we go.
Get it.
Nice.
All right.
A sacrifice.
Oh, look, I thought it would disappear sooner than it did.
Wait, did we get everything up here, too?
I think so.
Right?
Yeah, I think so.
I think so.
Why does it give us wings?
then.
Roblox hipster old head.
Hey, I'm not that old.
Wait, why does it give us wings?
No, no!
Why red?
Okay, good.
I didn't want to go through.
I thought I wanted to die.
I wanted to die.
Sweet, you can't say that.
I'm already dead.
It's fine.
Oh, you need to get the wings and then rush over here because there's a thing.
There's a gem.
Oh, I see it.
Oh, maybe I can get it.
Oh, yeah, I think you can get it.
Okay, okay.
Is that every...
Yeah, that's all of them.
Okay.
Yep, yep, yep.
That's all of them!
I'm fine!
Back in my day, Roblox used to be freaking awesome.
Back in my day, we played Second Life and we had no complaints.
What about back rooms?
Back rooms?
I think the only game I see people still playing is Dress to Impress, honestly.
Yeah.
Oops.
I don't know why I did that.
The only Roblox, like, game that I really like is that, like, there's, like, this one where...
Oh, nice.
This team, like, recreated, like, like, Universal Studios, like, almost one-to-one.
What?
That's crazy.
Yeah, it has, like, some differences, but it's pretty much, like, Universal Studios.
What?
That's crazy.
Yeah, like, with narration.
on the rides and stuff like that wait how are we supposed to get the boat into the i i don't know oh here we go now now pull it oh oh okay now we get rid of the other one come on i'll go back i just want to make sure there's no oh so smart oh wait uh oh i can probably wait oh no i can't do that oh wait oh wait oh wait oh oh oh oh
Okay, I'm not stuck.
Oh, you're good.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, and then I go here and then you go the other way?
Wait.
Or you go this way?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, why can't I?
Okay, hold on.
Let me, yeah, I'm coming, I'm coming!
Okay, here you go, there you go.
Okay, and then I go here.
No, no, I don't think.
No, okay.
I think we just get into the boat.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch out.
Whoa!
Oh!
go
oh man you gotta call the boat back though yeah i killed him though i killed him yeah you did hey i can't swim i can't swim oh wait i thought i was you for some reason i think there's a secret here oh you think so maybe why else would it would it be oh you think wait wait wait wait I can...
Maybe...
Unless it was telling us to, like, kill him.
I don't know.
Aww.
Like, how...
Like that?
I'm trying...
Oh.
Maybe not.
No?
Oh, maybe not.
But then I can turn off the...
I can turn off the thingy.
I can turn off the...
Oh, the fat...
Oh, wait.
I'll die?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, turn off this one?
Okay.
Oops.
Ha ha ha!
Oh wait wait wait and then...
And maybe we're overthinking it.
I don't know.
Maybe we are.
Wait.
I don't know.
Why else would it be there?
Yeah, why would it...
Why would it...
Guys, are we overthinking it?
Are we overthinking it?
Yeah, I think maybe that was the way to like kill him.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Yeah, bring it over here.
Bring it over here, boat man.
Alright.
Okay.
I keep thinking I'm you.
Oh, I know that happens to me too.
You gotta be different colors.
Why can't we be different colors?
Why is there so much noise all of a sudden?
Oh my gosh.
It's the...
I gotta go...
How do we do this?
Oh, you did it!
I got it!
I'm dead.
That's fine.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, like that.
Okay.
Wait, can we, like, kick it back?
No.
Ah.
You just...
Shoot.
Ah.
Oh, dang it.
Nice.
Wait, you almost got it.
I almost had him.
Oh, oh, I got you.
Ah!
My bad.
Why would you do that?
Alright.
Oh!
All right, that was my bad.
Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Nice, nice.
We kill him.
Okay.
Kill him.
Oh, oh, it fell.
It's, they have the paper bullet, dude.
I think that's alright.
Oh, what the hell?
Oh, I found a secret somehow.
How'd you do that?
I don't know.
I think we just fall through.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm waiting.
Run, run!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Oh my god, we're all on fire.
We're all on fire.
A man on fire.
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait, he eats everything.
Yeah, everything.
Did we get everything?
I don't know, but I can't imagine that we miss anything.
Did we get it all, guys?
Hey, I think...
No.
I think we can...
Doesn't seem like...
Oh, well...
That happened.
Yeah.
We're done now.
Into the next zone.
Seen clear.
Hell yeah.
Dang, we missed one.
Where was it, though?
Yeah, but we only missed one.
Yeah, sometimes it's seven.
Sometimes it's six.
Sometimes it's...
Sometimes we just miss everything.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
I kill him.
Oh, oopsie.
He's a pyromaniac.
I love the killing.
I love to kill you.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, my God.
Gosh.
Do you think there would be a gem nearby for them?
I'm just trying to kill them.
Oh my god.
This is so bad.
Wait.
I wonder if I change to...
There we go.
Oh, I killed one.
I killed one.
Okay, nice.
Oh my gosh, please.
Oh my gosh.
I just need the...
There we go.
You know what?
Screw it.
Uh-oh.
I don't think it reaches.
You gotta wait until this comes back and then I'll...
Oh, you got him!
Yeah, I'm sorry, I stole your kill.
It's okay.
Stolen valor is fine, you know.
I'm sorry.
Was there a gem?
I don't think there's a gem in it.
No, I don't think so.
I checked the sides.
Oh, here.
I'll jump on my shoulder.
Yeah.
Okay, thank you.
Okay.
Surely not a secret anywhere.
Right.
Maybe.
Oh, wait.
Oh, once we go through there.
Oh!
He won't come this way.
He's coming!
Oopsie!
It's okay, I got the checkpoint.
You might have to run.
Oh god.
Oh he's asleep!
You might have to run.
Oh!
Wait, oh gosh, I can't go that way.
I can't go that way.
Okay.
We're fine.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
Oh, and then we had to save the...
Is there anything up here?
There's gotta be some, yeah.
Whoa.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Oh, dang it.
It's okay.
Oh, there's a robot.
There's a robot.
What is that?
What the heck?
Who mentioned homing before?
These are, I think, bit more yeah yeah i think those are homing hold on i'll okay he doesn't oh i don't think you can kill them i think i think you have to just avoid them yeah run for it run oh i jumped too high oopsie oh okay i'm up here all right yeah yeah you got it you got it oh my mean toad oh what the hell I made it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Did you get the thing downstairs?
Was there anything downstairs?
Oh, I think so.
I think so, I think so.
Okay, okay.
What the hell?
What the hell is?
Oh, you gotta launch me.
Come here.
Come here, my bad boy, I'm coming.
I'm coming, I'm ruining something.
Oh, I don't think I can make that.
Or maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe I do.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Okay, and then you do that.
And then I do that.
And easy.
Yeah, easy.
Crazy, easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Easy, peasy.
Okay, I'm a little...
Oh, okay.
Oh, we did it.
That's all of them.
Oh, that's all of them?
Yeah.
The screen, like, does, like, a big, like, brrink.
Oh, I see what it is.
My ass is blind.
wait did we get all of them very good yeah i'm sorry i doubted you you did that's okay you gotta repent you doubted my genius oh look it's not green anymore so it's really yeah so this is did you teach mint what the hell or did she learn it herself she probably learned it on the tic-tac i did learn it on tic-tac i didn't do any of that Why'd you do that?
Oh, wait.
I thought it was a sequence.
One of these has to be, though.
Yeah, right?
One of them has to be.
I don't think any of them are.
Okay, just kidding.
Yeah, I don't...
The game is trolling us at this point.
Oh, there's...
Oh, my God.
Oopsie.
I drowned.
Minto drowned.
Oh.
Minto...
Wow, that's my favorite creepy pasta.
I love...
Just kind of saying it for like sometimes like Ben drowned Yeah It is a very funny phrase like out of context Yeah Okay go go go please Oh my gosh why can't I make it I'm so stupid Sorry I'm making it this time No you're fine Flappy bird Yeah flappy bird Oh shit Oh Wait Oh shit Oh shit Oh okay It works out Oops my bad Oh My bad.
Just wait for the comeback.
I guess do we...
Oh, wait.
You know what?
Maybe it's like, uh...
No, maybe not.
I thought it might have been a secret.
Oh.
No
way all the way back?
Okay.
Alright.
I'm here.
Okay.
You got it?
Oh, be careful.
No secret there.
Is there a secret down there?
I feel like there would be, right?
Yeah, right?
Should get the yard?
Oh, dang it.
I think maybe it's the other way, though.
Maybe.
Oh, toast.
We're getting toast.
Oh, shit.
Uh-oh.
Oh, okay.
It's on your way.
I'm on fire.
Oh, you were on fire.
You okay?
Yeah, I'm good now.
What is this for, though?
Oh, probably to block.
It was blocking the gem, yeah.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Let's go.
Okay, this might be the secret.
Ooh.
I think you probably have to wait until...
Wait.
Does that one move or no?
Oh, oh, oh, I think you need to bring the angel wings all the way here.
Oh, wait, where's the angel?
No way.
There's no way you can get through everything.
At the bottom.
Yeah, they're all the way there.
Oh, wait, there's some right here.
Oh, hold on, hold on.
Wait, there is?
Yeah, there's some below you.
Hold on.
Hold on, I'll get it.
Oh, you're right.
so smart i was gonna okay i was gonna go all the way i was like there's no way why am i here i don't know why am i here i don't know because the checkpoint is right here okay go just go just go oh be careful oh wait this is floppy bird it actually is it's actually floppy bird i got it oh wait i'm coming I'm coming.
I don't think I...
I don't think... Did we get everything?
I think it's too late.
I think... I didn't mean... I didn't know the exit was right there.
Shit, it's okay.
It's okay.
Just one mission.
Yeah!
Run!
Oh, secret, secret, secret.
Okay.
We have to redo it anyways, I think.
Maybe we follow him.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, you think so?
Or maybe it's like up here.
He's like kind of in this area.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
There's a, there's a, there's a, there's a, yeah.
Oh, oh.
Wait, what the?
Oh, oh, I think I launched you.
Oh, sorry.
I don't know what I was thinking.
Oh, wait, I think.
Okay, okay, I get it.
Okay.
Oh.
That's close.
Okay, hold on.
Peter,
oh, we're under the sea.
Oh.
Wait, this one's weird.
Where am I?
This one's weird.
I'm trapped.
Under the sea.
Whoa!
Gosh, I can't grab anything.
I'm stupid.
Don't say that about yourself.
Don't say that about my best.
Oh, wait, here.
Maybe I can, like, launch you, or can you, like, get on top of me?
Let me try.
I think I have to go back all the way through.
Like, luckily, it doesn't seem to be...
Oh, I got it!
Like, like, here, maybe?
Okay, try.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I think you just have to keep launching yourself.
How do you get up there, though?
Oh, oh.
Oh, try the other direction.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Oh, wait.
Maybe you do it.
Wait, I'm doing it.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah!
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, we didn't see the other one now.
Yeah.
Oh, whoopsie.
Oh, God.
It's kind of nightmare.
What the hell?
I hate this one.
Wait, there's a dev.
There's the dev in the chat.
Really?
Who's the dev?
Oh, dev in Minto chat.
Oh, hi.
Wait, I don't...
Oh, behemoth.
Behemoth!
Oh, behemoth!
Thank you for the gifted memberships.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you, behemoth!
Dude, get off my shoulder.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, hold on.
Ah.
Behemoth, when is the update coming out?
When is the update coming out?
Hi, have fun.
We love you.
I think I got all of them.
We love you too.
What the heck?
That was so cute.
Wait, did we get all of them?
Oh, we got the yarn.
Okay.
We got it, baby.
Where's the exit?
That's why I come over here.
No, I think that's on the other side.
Yeah, it's your side.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who?
No, we are patiently waiting for the update.
Thank you for updating this game, despite it being, like, 10 years.
10-plus years.
I know, right?
Holy moly.
That's crazy.
That's like a Terraria updating.
Oh, we got it.
We got time, too.
Nice.
Oh, we take it time.
Let's go.
Oh wait, we did complete it.
But we got a C.
I think because we didn't complete the actual level level.
Do you want to go back in?
Yeah.
Yeah, we can.
Let's do it.
I just want to say we've been getting perfect scores every time.
Yeah, because we're so good at this game.
You guys should give us our own skins.
Put me in the chat.
Put me in.
Oh, wait.
Huh?
Wait.
Oh.
I think you need to be here.
Maybe.
Okay.
Yeah, because I think they recently put out an update for Castle Crashers.
I didn't need to be here.
I don't think so.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, what is that?
Oh.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel bad for ignoring people.
yeah maybe maybe that's what you guys are into maybe that's why you're donating only during collabs and not during anything else you love being ignored they're just a little you know oh they're just a little freaky like that why did it put me all the way back down here oh wait i'm so curious what is that wrong thing why is there a button here i know what is that That's very strange.
Oh, I know.
Oh, don't do it.
Don't do it.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Be careful, be careful.
Oh, okay.
This is one at a time activity.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, they're not real.
Have you ever exposed yourself?
deep dark secret.
What's my deep dark secret?
About Laboobus.
What?
Oh, that I like Laboobus?
That you like them?
I like Laboobus, but...
You like Laboobus?
I kind of want one, but it would be like so cringe to get it now.
I think you could own it.
There's no such thing as cringe.
That's true.
Cringe is dead.
Yeah, cringe is dead.
Wait, there's...
Oh, I found it!
Wait, oh!
Wait, what?
How do I...
I said I found it, but I don't know what I found.
Oh, I found it.
Oh, wait, how did you do that?
Imagine.
Oh, what the heck?
Oh, oh, I thought I was you.
Get that guy.
Kill him.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You killed me.
Oh, wait.
Did the gem die?
Wait, he ate the gem.
No, he didn't.
Oh, no, he didn't.
I'm a liar.
He ate me.
Thank you for your sacrifice.
you're welcome oh wait here here i'll go go oh oh oh oh oh we got everything but what is this what is this what is that how do we get in there oh maybe it was a trap like the the moment you go for the ball of yard it dropped the boulder which enabled the lasers oh i think that's yeah i think that's what happened we just didn't Oh,
there.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we didn't notice.
Ah, we got it.
Dude, I want to play these, like, old...
Well, not really old, but, like...
You can say old.
Older.
Like, these older-type collab games are so fun.
I think they're so iconic.
This one's so fun, actually.
Yeah, I really like... It's the style.
Like, you don't really see a lot of indie games with this kind of style no more.
Yeah.
Like, new ground.
They're soulful, they are!
Hey, Behemoth, did you play the Meat and Bucks series?
Are they still here?
I don't know.
Imagine they're not here anymore.
I kind of want to know too.
I mean, they're probably like old Newgrounds heads, right?
Right!
That's like iconic.
What?
I'm never afraid to...
say my what i've you know my behavior yeah what was your favorite meat and fuck game what was your favorite new ground nsfw game oh gosh okay be careful i would actually like like to know because oh because like internet creation eras kind of were like what is it it was like first like nostalgia critic like angry video game nerd and then it kind of like morphed into newgrounds people and then go up and then it became and then it became like minecraft people i guess minecraft people yeah minecraft oops Oops.
Oh, wait, we try and use this to...
It is not a single linear thing.
Oh.
Oh, I'm scared.
Barry, I'm scared.
Don't be scared.
I'm scared.
Did you play, like, Henry Sickman and stuff, too?
I have not, actually.
I've watched, like, the Hollow Life girls played it play it yeah it's fine i don't know how many of the references you would get i'm not gonna lie i watched mark a flyer play it too oops worthy sacrifice is that everything wait it might have been oh no i didn't notice the i didn't either yeah oh maybe we missed something oh sorry oh god oh god secret right there i bet yeah clips are fine we love clippies clip every time i curse at mint you don't you don't yeah i never i would never say you mint to mint
how long did you want to play for today oh i'm down for anything i'm i just have something like super late at night, but I have plenty of time.
I have something late at night too.
Is it a date with me?
Yeah, we're going on a date afterwards, by the way.
We're going to Knotsbury Farm again.
Me!
Now we gotta go to Dollywood, actually.
I heard Dollywood.
Yeah.
Did you see that they're putting in the new ride?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Go ahead.
Sorry.
No, no, no, no.
I saw Dollywood won like a bunch of awards at the theme park.
Yes, yes.
yeah I want to go so bad and they're putting in a new ride that like is right now the technology is only used in this one park in France and it like it allows it so that it can become a roller coaster and a boat ride at the same time wait really yeah so it can like when you're in the boat on the water like it will like physically rock but like it's it's scripted rocking it's not like you know oh yeah it's I can't wait oh my gosh I'm so excited wait I didn't Dollywood was that lit and they put in a new ride.
That's like a grizzly bear roller coaster and it looks really cute and I want to I want to go.
Oh What the that sounds lit.
Yeah, I heard Dollywood is like really good.
Let's go to Dollywood.
I want to go.
Yeah It's cool.
Like there's like this little lever on the like this mechanism on the bottom of the boat goes in the water it extends and then when it goes back on land it like compresses so like it's closer to the track and then in the water it like turns into a boat and then on out of the water it turns into a roller coaster.
It's so cool.
I can't even imagine what that is, what that's like.
What the heck?
I know I want to try riding it so bad.
I was really impressed by the, I mean it was short but I really did like the Knotsbury Farm like the pony express.
Yeah, it was so short.
It was interesting.
It was so cool, yeah.
Yeah, it was very interesting.
I really like rides that are not, like, the typical where you ride, you, like, just sit down and...
Except the mouse trap.
Oh, my God, the mouse...
I don't think it was even called mouse trap, but there was this one ride and...
There was this one ride in Knotsbury Farm that had, like, an insane, like, whiplash.
Like...
You guys know the game, like, the board game Mouse Trap?
It was just like that.
And so we kept calling it mouse trap.
Yeah, it was like completely flat.
Or it was flatter than you'd expect.
And it was just turns and being flat.
And it was so violent.
It really hurt.
Yeah?
Oh my god.
Yeah, it was...
Mouse hunt?
Wild mouse?
Oh wait, what are those?
Yeah, wow.
There's like another ride that's like that.
I think it's like from I don't know actually I know Disney has a variation I think it's like Goofy's air ride Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I imagine that one probably is like the same so terrible Yeah and it was also backed up for some reason so we like stayed for like Oh we were burning in the sun for like 15 minutes Yeah like the ride Like the ride had already ended but there was a line to get off so we were just stuck in the cart like For like five minutes in the sun,
just baking.
So bad.
But also the worst part was like the lap bars.
They would come down.
But there was also like another lap bar by your shins.
That was just like...
So we all had like marks on our shins after we got off.
It was like...
It was so bad.
If you're tall, you would have a bad time.
Yeah.
Most fun, though, was definitely the Snoopy ride that we went on where we were, like, the only adults without children.
And they wouldn't let us two to a car.
It was only one.
So we took up, like, half the food.
Yeah, we, we, like, made, we, we, like, we, like, did not let the kids, like, go in the front where Snoopy was.
Like, where the big, uh, Snoopy, like, um, uh, what's it called?
mascot was like mint was at the very front yeah i showed my chat a picture of it i was like that's me sitting right behind snoopy who's driving the car we were like all screaming like freaking like we were very obnoxious about it okay but notsbury has like a like a number system of like how intense a ride is right and so we were like oh my gosh this one is a four out of five Why?
It was intense, you know?
You just get so excited seeing Snoopy and Woodstock.
I did.
I did get really excited.
Yeah.
We all got so excited.
I'm glad that the, because before we went on, the operator guy kept letting everyone go twice.
And he was like, one more time.
So I was like, oh man, we're like all adults.
I wonder if he's going to do that for us.
But he did.
We were like cheering.
I think it's like a scripted part of the ride.
But it's so good.
It's so good.
Extend the ride so you can get to go.
What other brides do that?
Unless it's, like, you know, end of the night or something.
I mean, we did technically go at the end of the night.
That's true.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
It was so fun.
Are you going to go back for Not Scary Farm?
I actually don't know.
Do they have, like, walking?
Like, I know Six Flags has, have, have people, like, walking around in costumes.
I, I, I, the Universal ones get crazier and crazier every year.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
I've never been to Universal Studios.
I want to go.
You never been at all?
No, not at all.
Well, maybe I went, like, maybe when I was younger.
Because I remember, like, the Homer Simpson donut ride when I was really young.
But I didn't really understand what it was.
But I've never been there, like...
Yeah, I've never been there.
Well, we could go to Dollywood and then go to Universal.
Yeah, in the same day.
In the same day.
Whereas Dollywood is Tennessee, right?
Tennessee, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We gotta go.
We're putting it down, yeah.
Mark it down.
Dollywood.
We gotta go with the theme park with those.
We gotta get Ashton too, because I don't want to go like...
Oh my gosh, we gotta go.
Bush Gardens?
I've never been to Bush Gardens either.
It's a...
Actually, I only know the Florida one.
I don't know if there's another one.
We have to go to the epic universe though.
Yeah!
It looks so good.
If we did like a couple days for Universal, I think it'd be better.
perfect oh yeah i guess universal is big enough now that that you should like set aside a couple of days oh i mean like maybe just well like one actually i don't know one day for universal one day for like the parks with like velociraptor and things like that velocicoaster and then one day for epic i guess so three days maybe right yeah because they're different lands i guess Wow,
sounds like fun Yeah, I don't think I want to go to Disney anytime soon Because it's so expensive nowadays Oh my god, American Disney is so expensive Yeah Yeah, I really like I really liked going to Tokyo Disney But My thing was that It pissed me off Because I haven't been to Disney World that much But I've been enough times to know that they were speeding up the damn rides Really?
Oh, some of them are crazy, yeah Yeah, if there's like enough people, I guess, they like start speeding up the ride.
So I remember like going on Peter Pan's flight.
And to be fair, the wait time was very, like it was like 40 minutes or something, like really short for Peter Pan's flight.
But it was like a minute long.
Yeah, because it's so popular.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
But they were speeding up the damn rides and I was like, what the freak?
The Snow White ride and the Pinocchio ride are like nonsensical because they're so fast.
You can't tell at all.
It's like a thrill ride at that point.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
It's fun.
I really, I was really confused by, because I've never really looked into Tokyo Disneyland, but I was really confused by, because my mom got this tour guide, or like a tour book.
And the tour book was like, oh yeah, the two most famous attractions here are the Beauty and the Beast ride, of course, right?
And the Baymax ride.
And I was like, oh, yeah.
Baymax ride.
Yeah, I was like, and I looked at it, or like we went online, or we looked at the line, and it was like two hours long.
It's always, it's always insane, the Baymax ride, because they just go nuts over him, and they go nuts over doing, like, the dances on the ride.
It's so, and I looked at it, I was like, that doesn't seem like a, like a thrill ride.
Why is it so long?
They love it, they love it for some reason.
Yeah, they know, like, the dances and stuff.
Yeah, I've never been on it, because it's always been so long, and I I'm like, is it worth?
Yeah, I feel like it's just like a you probably just have to know the dance moves and stuff.
Like, it's just a concert type thing.
But I was very confused.
It was very weird.
Yeah, it's kind of funny though, that they're like...
But the Beauty and the Beast ride is definitely worth.
Yeah, dude, I almost started crying.
I cried on that ride.
The first time I went on it, I was like, this is so beautiful.
I know.
I was almost... I almost cried, but they sat us next to, like, this little kid.
And I was like, I can't cry in front of this, like, small child.
Next time I go back to Japan, I'm going to try Fantasy Springs.
Oh, yeah, that's like, I don't even know what that is.
It's just like, it's not like Disney Springs, right?
It's like a different thing.
It's just an extension of Disney Sea.
So, like, they added Frozen, Rapunzel, and Peter Pan, I think.
Oh, yeah, I want to go to Disney.
Disney Sea sometime.
Come with me to Disney Sea.
I will go.
Oh my gosh.
You have to ride, you have to ride the Journey to the Sound of the Earth ride.
I will force you on that ride.
That's the, that's the one with the song, right?
Song?
I think there's like a song associated with that right.
I know it because, you know, Disney, Disney Japan always puts out that thing where it's like Ke no Oji-oji-sama?
I don't know.
Oji-sama.
It's this thing where they get, like, a bunch of male sayus to sing a bunch of Disney songs.
And I remember there was just one song that I didn't recognize that Junichi Sawabe sang.
And I was like, what the fuck is this song?
This is not Disney.
And I looked it up, and apparently it was from Disney Sea.
It was, like, from one of the rides there.
Yeah.
I didn't know that at all.
I learned today.
Yeah.
Koei no oji-sama.
Koei no oji-sama, okay.
I really like it.
I think it's super cute.
I like hearing Deku sing Coco.
He's like, remember me.
And he's like dressed though.
I know they make them perform it live at a concert too.
I love seeing my like middle age say you like fucking go up on stage.
That's so cute.
Perform the Disney song.
My special interests are colliding.
It's so awesome.
They had like, um, uh, Midori Kawa Hikaru and, I forgot his name, but Gilgamesh's voice actor sing Beauty and the Beast together, like, duet.
It's so fucking funny.
I really like it.
This is so good.
Yeah.
Okay, we'll go to Disney City.
We'll go to all the theme parks together.
Yeah, we'll do it.
It'll be so much fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
Have you heard, like, I don't know, I've never heard, like, I never, I guess I never listened to that song like, properly, and then I listened to it and like, Donald Duck is like screaming in the background.
Yeah, he gets like mad he's like, Donald Duck!
Yeah.
okay we gotta lock in okay we gotta lock in we gotta lock in oh what's scary oh what does oh nice nice nice i got you okay oh i just keep going oh i blew him up i blew him up oh wait why did you spawn back there i'm sorry i don't know it's okay oh oops wait is that is that oh i'm fine i'm fine wait did i mess up i might have messed up wait no no no no no you go on the ladder you go on the ladder oh sorry oh where did i oh okay Oh yeah,
because you go on the...
Oh my gosh, I grabbed it!
Skill issue, for real?
Okay.
Okay, no skill issue.
No skill, oh.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I didn't even go up there.
The ball of yarn is up there.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, how do you...
Oh, I see.
Oh, you actually get rid of him.
This thing is so dang fast.
It's, like, so hard.
Okay, I got rid of him.
Oh, God, oh, God.
I got rid of him for you.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm going.
Okay, wait.
I'm dying.
You got this?
Okay.
I think you need to go back down and get the jetpack.
I'm going.
Okay.
Nice.
Come back to me, Berrybug.
Oh, I'm coming soon.
Okay, there we go.
She's coming.
Not like that.
I'm not in Meat and Bug Kingdom.
Oh, how did that kill you?
I don't know.
Oopsie.
Uh-oh.
Okay, you made it.
Nice.
Get that gemmy.
Oh, it's so close.
It's okay, we got it, whatever.
Go, go, go, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Alright, whatever, whatever.
Alright, don't double jump there, don't double jump there.
Oh, oh, I thought I was you, fuck.
I see?
What is this?
Like that?
Oh, yeah, there you go, nice.
Go get the journey.
There's a teleporter right here.
Yeah.
Wonder how- Oh!
Oh!
Okay.
How does that work?
What does that do?
Is there like a sailboat that we need?
Uh-oh.
Our time.
Uh-oh, we're lost.
Team, we're lost!
Wait, oh, go to the teleporter!
Go through the teleporter!
Wait, you made me stuff.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, go through the teleporter.
Okay, I move this and then I go...
Other way, other way.
What?
What do you mean other way?
Other way, other way so I can go there.
Okay, just keep going, just keep going.
I'll teleport to you.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go go go go go go go go go!
Oh god, not nice.
Our time!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh shoot, okay, go go go go go!
Ah!
It's okay, we know what to do now.
Oh, oops.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're distracted, it's okay.
Oh, I just kept walking.
Oh, why do I- why does it spawn me there?
Why does it spawn me there?
Please!
Oh my god!
I'm...
It's okay, it's okay!
I'm in my flop era!
Don't say that!
Okay, I'll go here, you wait over there, I guess.
Am I getting the...
Oh, oopsie.
Okay, yeah.
I'll kill this guy?
Okay, okay.
Alright, I'll get it.
And then you go...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oops.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I got it, you got it.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, you got it.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're fine.
You have time, you have time, you have time.
Oh.
Okay, I'll go.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, oopsie.
Okay.
All right.
We know what to do at least.
We won't fuck up here.
Oh, wait.
I'm just...
What are you laughing about?
Minito?
Oh.
I didn't even see that.
Yeah, I noticed.
I noticed it.
Oh, I've been noticing this.
Yeah.
She's smart.
And then I go this way.
Yeah.
And then, and then.
And then you push.
Yeah, and then we go this way.
All right, perfect.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Okay, let's go.
Nice.
And then, how do we get this one down here?
We go here.
Definitely.
And then we go here.
I got it.
You got it?
Yep.
Oh, okay.
I was able to turn this off.
We got it.
Okay, okay, nice.
Was that everything?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, oh, oh, I have to turn on the thing again.
Hold on.
Oh.
Okay.
Like that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Our brains are expanding.
Okay.
All right, let's see what we got going on here.
You got it?
I got this.
All right.
guys oh oh what the hell i think i think you have to put it on the thing again yeah yeah there we go okay i go here okay and how do i help you um that's a great question just keep going just keep going wait i got it baby oh no i don't have it oh hello um go oh uh okay okay nice when i go and then Just,
uh, keep going.
Just, just die?
Me?
Okay, I'll die.
Oh, okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's just, yeah, just...
Oh, no.
Okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
Our blains, our blains are not...
Our blains!
Oh my god, be careful.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Ah, wait, ah!
Uh, okay.
Wait, so do I just pergrap?
like the whole time without you I have no idea like that's that's so strange okay I got it here okay I'll just uh okay here we go yeah oh my gosh okay oh my gosh okay oh dang it
I know I know you've been on like a a retro game kick recently yeah okay I got another one I'll let you have it let you have it.
Wow.
Oh.
Oopsie.
I tried to kill him.
Oh, we have to turn off the fan.
Nice, nice.
Oh, did I do that?
Someone did that.
I don't know.
Okay, cool.
Oh.
Let's see the hat.
You got it?
Yeah, we only have 15 seconds, though.
Once there's Wings again, I'll Flappy Bird.
Flappy Bird, Flappy Bird!
Oh, Flappy Bird!
Um, wait.
The key's right there.
Okay, okay.
Go!
Get him!
Ah!
Okay.
It's okay, we know what to do.
Yeah.
This one's like strange though.
Okay.
Do you want me to go through it?
Uh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or here, you can do it.
already know the pattern.
I'm going.
You know everything.
Oh.
You got this.
Nice.
She's gaming, everybody.
Okay.
What about that gemmy?
I got it here.
Yep.
Okay.
Nice.
I feel like that's not the intended way.
I don't know.
I don't think so, but who cares?
Who cares, I guess?
Who cares?
Oh, that's fine.
Okay.
Got us more time.
Good night.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Uh, uh.
How did you, did you kill him last time?
I guess I did, but I don't know how.
Um.
Yeah!
There we go.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, dang it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, dang it!
What, no, hat this time, Stampy?
Yeah, Stingy!
You're stingy, man.
What the hell?
That guy's actually stingy.
None this time!
Alright.
Oh, dang it.
Oh my gosh, how are you supposed to get this far?
I think you have to distract him over here, no?
Oh, yeah, probably.
Oh, dang it!
Okay.
Hello, hello, sir.
Hello, okay, I think he's focused on me.
No, he's not.
Go get it.
Okay, nice
Your legs your legs your legs I'm one inch taller than you
You've really got the crowd eating from your delicate hands now there's never a dull moment with you at the helm Except for maybe like twice, but I gotta hand it to you.
You've got quite the unbreakable spirit I mean, I'm not nearly as brave as you.
If I was in your capably nimble shoes, I'd say to heck with Hattie and my friends, yeah, heck with Hattie.
Now, pack myself a nice bag lunch, show these cats my favorite finger, and then I'd make like horse turds and hit the trail.
But I'm not you, and you're not horse turds.
No, sirs.
You are the very definition of the cat's PJs.
That is so cute.
These cats are truly bizarre.
Why can't we dress up like that?
I mean, I've got my theories.
Yeah.
Oh, aliens from another world.
Alien.
How could it be that they were once normal kitties?
Normal kitties who evolved into the strange, unpleasant creatures we see before us?
These hideously adorable abominations with their beady eyeballs.
Giants, bloodthirsty, tiny mouth fangs, slashy paw claws, and slashy funk traps.
Plus, they're awfully rude and crappy.
I think they all need girlfriends or something.
I'm a cat, see?
Does your cat need a girlfriend?
I like to run around all day.
I like people's feelings.
They don't really know.
They like each other, but they're not.
Maybe he's just chill like that.
Yeah.
They're always watching children.
I see them lurking in the shadows.
Lurking hard.
Oh.
Say.
Like a bad joke.
How did things get so bad?
At one time this theater was a nice place with flowers in every vase and smiles on everyone's mouth.
Yeah.
Can you believe it?
I wouldn't believe it.
But then he died and the cats ate his food.
They probably did, yeah.
Find a place to get ice cream to replenish the innocent you back in with your filthy deceits.
I want ice cream.
Just keep your wits about you as you descend deeper into the belly of the beast.
Do you like mid-chocolate chips?
I do!
No freaking way.
Hell yeah, we did it.
Hell yeah.
Oh, now he's cleaning it.
Yeah.
Wait, how did I get up there before?
I think you jumped on me.
There we go.
Oh, you can jump on here.
Actually, we have the same idea.
It was the silence.
How many chapters are in this game, guys?
I actually don't know.
Does anyone know?
There's at least a five and six, apparently.
I'm going to go gotchas.
Or maybe...
No, maybe not achievements.
24?
I think you're lying to me.
Yes.
Eight?
Oh, okay.
So this is like halfway?
We're like halfway?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, I have some fucking gems.
Oh, I have 60.
You have how many?
60?
Oh, let's go.
What are you gonna get?
I kind of want to, I kind of like the squares.
Go square!
Oh!
Oh, that was cute!
That one's so of the era.
Wait, that's cute!
Why did you keep getting cute ones?
You got a cat!
What?
Oh, you got another George Washington.
What the hell?
Why am I so George Washington coded?
I don't know.
Okay, I'm gonna get some too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah, good, good.
You changed it to him.
Cute.
Oh, I got a cat too.
Yeah, that's cute though.
That is so cute.
Wait, I like it.
I love his smile.
Yeah.
Snick!
What the heck?
It's actually in.
Snick!
Oh, what the f-
It's a nerd!
Oh, I like this one too.
It's cute.
Mommy!
Oh.
Hippopotamus.
No comment.
Oh, I got the scarf!
Spinner!
Wait, do you want that one?
Well, which one do you want of mine?
You want the cat?
No, no, you can keep a cat.
It's so funny.
I mean, I'll give you the spider.
Yes, please.
I can give you...
Wait.
Actually, you know what?
I feel bad.
Have the Washington.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, great.
Thank you.
How do we...
Ding bong!
Oh, I think you need to press...
Yeah!
There you go, now you're spitter.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh!
Let me have your new face.
I love your new face.
I don't want to be square anymore.
What, you don't like?
You don't like my Washington that I gave you?
Uh, not quite a fan, maybe.
Oh, what is that?
An energy ball?
Whoa, what is that?
Is that a vacuum?
What is that?
A lawnmower?
Oh, I think I got the thing you got.
Oh, I got a boomer- Wait, I got a toad?
A toad?
Oh, Mario!
It just sucks you close.
What the fuck?
What is that?
Oh.
And then I can punch you.
Wait, can I- Wait, can I do your grenades?
Like throw them?
Oh, maybe, maybe, hold on.
Let me see if I can suck it.
Oh, oh, wait.
Was that a frog?
Wait, did that again?
Yeah, that was a frog.
Hold on.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
Oh, whoops.
Here, I'll throw a grenade at you and you see if you can suck it.
And I'll suck it.
Okay, here.
Oh, wait, that's not a...
That's a frog.
Okay.
I don't know how to...
I don't know how to switch it.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, he did suck it.
That's funny, he kind of is just like, Oh, no, I sucked it.
Jeez.
Wait, okay, hold on.
And then I got this one too.
Wait, how did you explode?
I threw a grenade at the same time and it bounced back to me.
And then I got this one.
Wait, which one?
Wait, what did you just do?
I just threw you up.
Oh.
Whoa!
Oh!
Kamehameha.
Oh, it goes up, though.
A frog!
He's so dapper!
He is!
I don't know if he's dying.
Oh.
He's invincible.
This one kind of sucks, though, because it goes up.
Yeah, it only, like, pushes you.
Yeah.
Wee!
Let's see.
Nice.
Look at us.
We're kind of like fitted.
I know, right?
Oh my gosh.
We're so, we're so in it now.
We're so, we're so trendy.
What do the kids say nowadays?
Yeah.
Oh, no, go ahead.
Oh, they say, uh, swag.
Swag.
Yeah, we're so swag.
We're not chopped, you guys.
Oh, we're not chopped.
It's true.
We're so skimpy or whatever.
Next time, next time.
we'll do red and then you'll really look like with the spider you'll look so true yeah yeah six seven or whatever i don't understand that meme okay i saw a video that was like explaining it the other day i was like yeah uh-huh because i don't think anybody understands it i think it's just oh oh it's just a so basically brain rot yeah there was like a there was like a guy that like said six seven and a song and then there was also like a basketball player and he's six seven and so then they would try and get him to say six seven for some reason and then um there's like yeah there's like an edit i don't know i've tried to explain it before and each time more time passes since i watch the explanation so i remember less and less of it oh what the heck Oh my god,
wait, do you know the Secret of the Mimic song?
No.
Oh, I have to show you something later.
It's so good.
It's a fan parody of the FNAF game Secret of the Mimic, and it's really good.
Okay, I'm excited.
Yeah, it's really good.
I'm sure it is.
Yeah.
You know the my name is Edwin And I made the mimic Yes, yes, yes, yes That song Yeah, it's that song Oh, I didn't know that one Oh, my God Wait, let's still send it to me Yeah, send it to me Yeah, yeah, yeah, you should listen to the full version Because it's very good That's not even like top five lines to me Oh,
wow, okay Oh, okay
Alright, you ready for some 4-1?
I think actually I might call it here if that's okay.
Oh yeah, that sounds good.
I mean, it is the halfway point anyway.
Yeah, I think we're halfway, so then we can maybe beat it next time.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, hold on.
Let me send you the mimic song.
Okay.
Jackie's box.
Is this where we're at?
You don't have to listen to it now, but I would love to hear you listen to it.
Okay, I will listen to it on stream and react to it.
Yes!
Yeah, it won't get struck or anything.
Oh, it will?
Oh, perfect.
Okay.
I don't think so.
I played it multiple times on stream and I don't think I got struck.
Well, most of my streams get struck nowadays anyway, so it's fine.
No, man, no.
It's okay.
Yay!
Yeah, Otsuminto!
Otsuminto.
Very.
Very?
Very bug.
Join us next time for when we stream this game while we're at Dollywood together.
Oh my gosh, you'll be right next to me.
And then I can sabotage you for real.
I can like knock the controller out of your head.
What?
You wouldn't do that, would you?
You wouldn't do that to me.
Grab your butt so that you would get distracted.
What?
What are you saying?
What I would do?
What?
I guess you did put your face in my boobies, so there's only...
There's only...
I gotta get the top and the bottom.
From head to toe, baby.
Dude, I gotta, I gotta, I gotta do it to you too.
I gotta like, I don't know, grab your ankles while you're like walking and I'm just like under the bed and I'll just grab your ankles and make you scream.
That's actually scary.
I'll be like, Oh my god, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
And you'll like, you'll like kick me in the face.
Happy one.
yeah oh yeah you're pretty good she's a little freak you guys oh oh i still think about the you're pretty good exercise you're pretty good
yeah i came up with that yeah did you do it did you do your exercises i did i did i actually i woke when when no I woke up a little bit before when you woke up and then I saw you like get out of bed and start like doing stretches like those stretches I was like oh I guess mint like wakes up and immediately does stretches she's very like health conscious I guess but then it was just I think you were just coming up with ideas with a metal gear channel I thought you were like super like health conscious I was like oh like I guess like as soon as she wakes up she and like it warms up her body that's so cool okay well i do i do get out of bed and i do do jumps i do jumps every morning yeah that kind of counts yeah yeah one two three four
we're so bouncing yeah she's warming up it is i can't wait for you to get the model update and then you could be like thanks for the super chat Um, I could say, uh, thanks for the super time!
Yeah, get their asses.
Yeah.
You can't see it, but she's licking her knife.
Oh.
She's being a little freak.
But thank you, Minto, for collabing with me.
It was freaking awesome.
and finish it and we'll play a bajillion other games together and then we'll go to Dollywood together yeah we'll also play PT together yeah and things will be awesome awesome awesome yeah I feel like I feel like now that the or most of the fire is out in the public now we don't have to be yeah I feel like the last few times we met up,
we were just like, um, we're dying.
We would have like beat up, but we'd be like, um, are things okay?
No, things are not okay.
We'd just be like, how are you doing?
I'll be honest though, Mary, I don't think I would have gone to the Metal Gear pop-up if you hadn't gone also.
What the?
Yeah.
Of course.
I don't think I would have gone if I didn't talk to you about it too.
I think we kind of just like, we're just like, Yeah, I mean, we could stop by for, like, a day, maybe.
It's like a...
Yeah, a quick little trip.
Yeah.
It was really fun, though.
The Delta...
I mean, you already played Delta at this point, but the Delta, like, preview was really nice.
I remember I sat next to Mr. Vinny Vine Sauce, and I was like...
You did?
Yeah, I was...
Yeah, I was giving him the side.
I was like, are you...
You're like someone I know...
You're like...
Yeah, I sat next to him.
Everybody donate to Barry so she can get a new PC and play Delta.
No, no, I'm just late.
I'll bring it to a micro center soon.
I'm just a little lazy.
Wait, does Minto know about the Leon Sext Kennedy story?
Were you, I don't know.
Were you in like the vicinity when I was like briefly talking to him.
Maddie and I were talking about Resident Evil.
I think I might have been there.
Oh, wait, I think I was.
Because we were talking about Resident Evil, yeah.
Yeah, we were talking about Resident Evil, and I said Leon Sex Kennedy as a joke.
And Vinny was like a little, like, was like, um...
He was like nearby, and he, like, whipped his head to me.
Because I think apparently, like, his fan base calls, likes to call him, like, Leon, because he looks like him, kind of, maybe.
So I, like, unknowingly, like, said...
express to do stop harassing people barry i know i can't do this anymore i can't show my damn face to mr vinnie vine sauce no more oops sorry vinnie vine sauce mr vine sauce i apologize on behalf of this bug um continue doing uh i really like your your video with the snake with the Ocelot coming out of his crotch.
That's not the- You keep describing it that way.
Because that's what happened!
That's what happened!
Ocelot's head came out of his crotch!
I love that video so much.
I was watching it at, um, I forgot where I was going.
I think it might have been, like, last year's MGSCon or something like that.
I was watching it at the airport and I started, like, like, crying, laughing.
At the, at the, at the gate.
Because I was watching it for the first time.
For people that don't know, he did like a glitch run.
And it like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you could describe it that way, or you could describe it as the video where Ocelot goes out of this crowd.
And that's how Barry chooses to describe it instead of being normal.
I thought people would die.
I thought people knew what I was talking about.
It's a really funny video though.
You guys should look up vine sauces, MGS3 corruption.
Okay, now that you say it like that, I understand why it's strange.
I think I might have, like, described the video like that to Vinny as well, to be honest.
And I think you did.
You did.
Yeah, I think that explains why he took a second to, like, realize what I was talking about.
Well, you're just describing your favorite part, so, you know.
Yeah, yeah, I was just like, I'm not, like, a huge fan, but I like some of your videos.
Sorry, man.
What?
Can you do that again?
Can you make him come out of the garage again?
Can you make him, can you make his eyes pop out of his socket while he looks at his garage again?
Sorry, Mr. Vinny Vine saw us for such testing you.
It was fun though.
It was good stuff.
It was a lot of fun.
Yeah, we took a lot of, we took a lot of pictures of the boss in the room and the with the flowers.
Yeah.
Maddie, Maddie got us flowers from the exhibit.
They're really like, like good quality too.
I know, it's such good quality.
Yeah, yeah, Maddie with the geese.
I love Maddie.
Maddie's so freaking fun.
I love her.
She's so tall though.
I'm like, I'm like, hi Maddie.
Hi Maddie.
We're both down here.
Yeah, we should all, we had also invite Maddie.
She likes theme parks too.
So, we should.
We need to go to Disney Sea all together.
Yeah!
That would be a lot of fun.
Like more adult stuff, right?
Or like more thrill stuff, like more intense.
Yeah, there's a bit more thrilling things, yeah.
I want to go.
That would be the best day ever for me!
It would be so freaking epic!
Yay!
It's in the spirit of the game.
It's Newgrounds era.
Oh yeah, oh, that's why I was like, oh wow, epic.
Also, epic is just freaking, it's just fun to say, you know, epic, awesome sauce.
Oh, awesome sauce.
Bring them back.
Yeah.
You need to bring it back.
Freaking awesome sauce, man.
Freaking epic, man.
I'm freaking firing my laser.
Hacksores.
Hacksores?
You're just got pooned.
Raffle copter.
You just got freaking pooned, man.
Well, you just lost the game.
How could you do that?
I I unironically got a TikTok the other day that was just like, you just lost the game.
And I was like, oh, this is my feed.
This is what I've catered.
How did they know?
This is...
Bro, what year is it?
Dude, it's 2013, man.
Battle Block Theater just came out, man.
That's when this came out.
Oh, 2013?
Yeah, 2013, I think?
That's what it said on the YouTube thingy.
On the YouTubes.
My Laboobo YouTube.
My Laboobo.
I love the way she says Labo.
Labobo.
Yeah, it's so, like, addicting to hear.
Like, I don't think I can say it normal.
I'm like, Labobo.
My 24-carat girl Labobo.
Labobo.
Well, thank you so much, guys, for coming.
I think I'll stream, like, for a few minutes longer just to thank everybody.
But, uh, just to thank, like, the subs and everything.
Yeah.
But thank you for coming to the Minky Drowned stream.
Minky Drowned!
Oh, my gosh, wait, I should create that as, like, a game.
You should play it, what is it, Ocarina of Time?
Or was it Majora's Mask?
I feel like it was Majora's mask is the spooky one so I feel like it's always yeah yeah yeah probably you should you should get like a 3d model of just uh minke running around I know I know you should just drown when you can yeah October's coming up you guys be ready for some spooky stuff spooky spooky it's already spooky season it really is almost no it is it is now oh it is okay okay declares it so.
It's now.
Spooky.
Oh my god.
You're blue Dabba DB.
Dabu.
Labubu.
Scrooby.
Yeah.
Did you have anything?
Oh wait.
There's also Minky is gonna have her 3D concert sometime soon.
I forgot the, I don't know if you said the exact date, but...
It's October 1st, my birthday!
Yeah!
Alright!
Oh my god, I'm such a fake fan.
Yeah!
I'm so sorry.
I'll bury.
Yeah, she's gonna have her 3D concert, and she's...
Uh...
And she worked really hard on it, I think, I'm assuming.
And And, of course, she always does.
And you guys should check it out because she's awesome.
She's freaking epic.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm freaking epic.
Yeah.
So you...
I'm awesome, Shosh.
What do you got going on, Barry?
Awesome, Shosh.
I'm going to fix my sleep schedule.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, I'm going to have my sleep study soon.
I'm probably going to do it tonight, actually.
Oh.
Yeah, my at-home sleep study that finally my insurance fucking approved.
Oh, wait, I didn't realize you had an actual thing going on.
I feel like, I don't know, you've seen me multiple times just like falling asleep everywhere.
But like, I don't know.
I'm just like really tired.
I don't know if it's just like I'm just broken or like if there's like I have an actual thing going on.
So I just wanted to check if I did have an actual thing going on.
That's fair.
I was so sleepy whenever I would meet up with you.
Minta would be like, I'm gonna lay down on this park bench and fall asleep.
I know, you were, we had to go get you a burger and bring it back to the hotel room.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I remember at Knott's very far, at Knott's very far when you went to go write Ghost Rider one last time.
I like literally was sleeping on the picnic bench.
I was like laying down, I was like, I'm so sleepy.
Okay, but to be fair, that was like the longest.
longest day that we it that this is it really we did a lot we did so much we made sure to maximize yeah we min max that part baby oh my goodness well i'll talk to you later mayor yeah thank you for hanging out bye whips bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye Bye bye!
Bye bye!
Get out!
You're okay, baby.
Bye!
Okay.
I left the score.
I like how the pen lights are different colors.
It's so cute!
Yay!
Like a real bug.
Wow, she's so small.
She's on my head, very bad.
But thank you guys!
Let me exit the game.
Wait, how do I exit the game?
Oh, oh!
Wait.
We were unable to join the match.
Well, well, let me out.
Wait, one second.
Uh, oh.
Controller, connect!
Okay.
Exit game.
Save your progress and exit, yes.
Oh, no.
Save my progress and exit, yes.
Oh,
that was so fun!
Wait, this is actually such a fun game.
This is actually so fun.
And Dev and Chat, that's always so exciting.
It's okay to ask for the only saying birthday song.
Ducky, happy birthday!
Okay, just only saying birthday.
Birthday.
Birthday!
Yay!
Support naming the collab Bento.
I like Bento so cute.
Voltaku Energy and Barry plus Minto.
Yeah, I think Bento was really, really cute.
Oh, she got that cash money.
Dang, girl.
And here I am.
I got nothing!
She's got the body!
Ah!
But I'm so happy I'm friends with Barry.
She and I, we actually have so much fun.
Like we just, when we hang out.
In collab, we haven't really collabed so much, but we've always hang in game.
And when we hang, when we play, when we hang out.
Oh my gosh, she's got the glasses too!
I don't want to update my, my achievemento.
I want the new stuff.
I want the new stuff!
Thank you so much for being such a good ghost to my Oshi.
You two are so awesome together always.
Thank you!
You were really grilling nothing?
I'm grilling nothing.
This is so messed up!
Exit game.
Very good.
is impromptu yapp sessions yeah also because like Barry likes theme parks too so we have that kind of niche in common but I did I did a stream with her once where we where we
where we talked about theme parks me ashton and Barry and then also I keep getting cloud error recently on my on my steam I wonder why but um and then also one time Barry joined me when I was too afraid to play a horror game so my
nose has been so yeah
you remember that yeah so I've I've uh I have played with the Barry a couple times look at it on my little head
Barry's my buddy Mary's my friend But I don't know I don't know what it is But I've just been so tired today And yesterday Today and yesterday I'm glad I didn't I'm glad I did not stream yesterday Because I was so like I was so I think I can knock her off
I don't think I could So I think I'll just...
I wanted to keep playing, but I'm just kind of...
I don't know, the past couple of streams have been so low energy.
I apologize.
And I don't know why I'm lagging a little bit.
Get the bug zapper.
I'm also out of water.
Hold on, I'm gonna...
Get a cough drop.
Yeah, maybe I need a sleep study too.
I'm
gonna head out guys Thank you so much for a collab It was so fun And I hope that you had fun And this was fun And I love Berrybug And I will see you guys when I see you Tomorrow I'm playing Mystery of the Druids Which is another game I've never Actually almost all this week Were games that I've never played before So that was fun battle block theater so I would uh so Barry and I will be back baby we'll be back so
thank you everybody thank you so much thank you thank you thank you thank you Barry Barry streams on Twitch by the way so get the GOG version I already did I already looked that up so no worries no worries I saw the reviews I always check stuff like that and I saw that everybody for Mystery of the Druids was just like Steam version is broke,
go get the go get the GOG version, so she double streams on YouTube!
What?
I didn't know that.
Oh, I'm a bad friend too.
Well,
yeah, then go to Barry's YouTube channel.
Barry Bug.
Okay.
Anyway.
What was I saying?
Oh, Asabita!
Asabita!
What's a bug?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
I will see you guys later.
See you next.
Bye-bye.
I didn't mean for it to be so big.
I'm bad.